Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
My God, I feel like...
It's... oh my God, it's fine.
I don't know, I'm just really out of it.
It's so early in the morning as well.
It's like, what do you feel, Doki?
Please tell... I don't know anymore.
I don't know what to feel anymore, guys.
I don't know.
Oh my God.
I need to let you guys know that...
I still have yet to unpack my bags.
You know, since Japan...
My suitcase is still all packed up in the corner of my entrance.
I literally just pushed my suitcase in the corner of...
You know, in the corner of my entrance.
And then I was like, I'll get to you tomorrow.
And then I do that every day.
Every day I walk Doki Amber Doge, I look at my suitcase and I'll be like...
Don't worry, tomorrow would be the right time.
But, starting tomorrow.
Start not today, sorry.
No, starting today!
You know what?
No.
Starting today!
Because I'm doing a livestream there.
And that's a deadbolt.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome back to Ikemen Warriors Origin Fujoki Bird.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Starting today, I will be so much more productive.
We are going back to the productive Doki Bird days.
No, no, we're not gonna go on vacation or anything.
We're gonna go back to the grind.
We're gonna organize stuff again.
Starting today, I will unpack my suitcase tomorrow.
For sure, this time, tomorrow.
I will be a peak productivity Doki Bird.
For sure, for real, guys.
Starting today.
Tomorrow, I'm unpacking my suitcase.
Also, did you guys know that they finally discovered who Jack the Ripper was?
And his name is Aaron.
As I was looking on Twitter, people were like, Why is no one freaking out about this?
We have finally discovered who Jack the Ripper was.
And his name is Aaron.
Yeah, apparently.
Apparently, via like DNA testing.
Well, I'll show you guys the Twitter article I was reading.
By the way, it's on Vice, by the way.
He's like apparently some fucking barber or something.
It's not, was never a doctor.
It was just a barber from Poland.
But, sorry, Aaron.
Sorry, I meant to say Aaron.
But yes, that is apparently who Jack the Ripper was.
So now, like, you know.
Now it's cool, I feel like.
I feel like, you know, knowing he's just a barber from Poland.
Now that's like, also he died in a mental asylum.
So it's like, oh, he was just crazy, you know.
There wasn't like some fucking doctor that was practicing or whatever.
He's just crazy.
It's just, it's not so cool anymore.
The mystery of it was like, he was never cool.
Say that to the millions of films and TV shows.
And women be like, oh, Jack the Ripper.
Oh, if you were alive right now, I'd let you murder me.
So like, Sweeney Todd.
No, Sweeney Todd's cooler because like, he made them into pies.
Oh, you think I'm wrong?
Look at the women that send like, mail over to like, you know.
People who are at death sentence.
Prisoners and women sending fan mail to them.
Be like, oh, I can fix you.
If you ever get out of prison, I'd marry you in a heartbeat.
You're so hot.
Oh my god.
Anyway, so...
So yeah, no, she's not as cool.
I don't know, it just ruined Jack the Ripper for me.
I thought he was like...
The mystery behind him was just much more interesting than finding out that his name is A-A-Ron.
I don't know.
The mystery is just, I'd rather it be like, unknown.
Yeah, reality is often very disappointing.
I'd rather it be like, unknown for the rest of my life than finding out that his name was A-A-Ron.
For those that don't follow me on Twitter!
For those that don't follow me on Twitter.
And I'm sorry if you weren't invited to the exclusive Doki Amber Doge birthday party.
I'm very sorry, guys.
Look, the list was very exclusive.
And, um, she just didn't pick you!
Except for one lucky dragoon.
One lucky dragoon was able to come to the party.
But I have, I think this is like, my favorite photo I've ever taken of him for this year.
Because, uh, so like, when I was at the dog bakery, they had a cowboy hat.
And I was like, I need it.
And I love, I love, I love his side eye.
Howdy, partner.
This town ain't big enough for the two of us.
I think the side eye has to be one of my favorite, like, photos I've ever taken of him.
And then here's him, here's that one lucky dragoon.
The one lucky dragoon that, uh, got an invitation to the party.
You guys!
There you guys are!
Look!
See?
That's you over there!
Yes, you!
You got invited to the party!
Congratulations!
Yeah!
It's the dragoon!
Um, so that's the one lucky dragoon that got invited to the party.
And then here's like, here's the, uh, birthday cake too.
Um, we're joking.
Also, here's like a piece of chicken.
Chicken toy right there.
I spent $200.
Here's him eating his cake.
He's like, yum, yum, yum.
It should've been me!
Like, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, here's him eating his cake.
Yum, yum, yum.
$200 Canadian dollars.
No, it's not just the cake.
Not just the cake.
It was also the cowboy hat, the little, um, the dragoon plushie, the little, um, uh, the chicken toy.
And I also bought two extra treats, like a burger-shaped treat, and then also like a chicken drumstick-shaped treat.
And, um, I also bought him a little birthday hat too, but he did not like the birthday hat.
He really liked, for some reason, he was okay with the cowboy hat, but he did not like the birthday hat.
I tried to put the birthday hat on him, then he's like, no.
Mother, why would you do this to me?
But yeah, he was not happy with that.
But at least I got...
At least I got, uh...
At least I got the cowboy hat, though.
The cowboy hat made him feel so cool.
Honestly, I'm not gonna lie, like, valid.
Very, very valid.
But starting today, I'm gonna be so much productive.
I'm gonna get everything, not everything done, I'm gonna get some things done today.
And then, um...
And then I'm, uh...
I'm gonna unpack my suitcase tomorrow.
We're gonna be back on track.
This week was more so of, like...
I know, like, I just got, like, I was like, oh, this week is where I'm gonna get things back on track.
But this week was more so of, like, I went to sleep.
I spent most of my days just catching up on sleep.
I finished sleep, and then I was like, sleep time!
And I would be like, it's the next day.
And I'm like, oh, God.
That's... oh, no.
Oh, no.
This week is my week, for real, for real.
A liar.
No, my manager is not happy.
He is...
He's not happy!
He's like, where are you?!
And I'd be like, sorry.
I'm sorry, I just woke up.
And then, like, I did, like, a morning call today.
Like, you know, when I woke up, I was...
Cause, like, to catch up on work, cause I was not there yesterday night.
I was...
I was not there.
I was not alive.
And then, cause, like, after the very exclusive...
I mean, I was partying with my dog!
Okay, guys?
I was partying with my dog, okay?
Like, my very exclusive...
It was a great...
You guys should have been there for the exclusive musical guest, guys.
Oh, my God.
Like, I can't say who it was that was there.
DJing for Dad's party, because, like, I signed an NDA.
But, oh, man.
You should have been...
Oh, I wish you guys were invited, guys.
I...
And to the lucky Dragoon that was there.
That got to see who the exclusive musical guest was.
You signed an NDA, too, so you can't reveal it as well.
Anyway.
But, yes.
And then, like, I called my manager to get, like, here's the update on what y'all have to do.
And what I haven't been doing.
And, like, what I need to, you know.
And then, they were like, did you walk Doki Amber Doge yet?
And I looked at my clock, and it was, like, 15 minutes till stream start.
And I was like, oh, fuck!
And then my manager was like...
I'll update you tomorrow.
Or tonight, then.
So yeah, anyway.
I fed him before I got the call, though.
But, yes, anyway, so don't worry.
Like, I said, today...
Today's where productivity goes up.
Today.
That's it.
And to kick things off, we do a long stream.
Today is where things are different!
Today is that day!
Gee, who would've thought?
Today is the day where we have a long stream.
And it's not because of my rivals.
Today is that day!
Don't worry, trust in me, guys.
I need you guys to trust in me or it's not gonna work, okay?
With the power of belief, we can make sure that today is that day.
We do not stop until we hit at least three to four hours, guys.
That's the goal.
Anyway, we are back with Dynasty Warriors Origin.
We weren't able to continue last time because I think I was sick or something.
I don't know.
I feel like my body has been breaking down a lot.
That's why I needed more rest lately.
But today is that day where we're gonna play a long time.
We stopped at the perfect moment where Guan Yun was like...
He was like, why don't you come into this tent in more ways than one?
And I was just like...
And then it faded to black and I was like...
What just happened?
I was just like...
Where did I go?
Apparently, I was reading, I was watching a clip.
And people were saying like...
Oh man, no.
It's just...
Because they're like, oh, maybe it's just the English translation.
People were just getting a little too spicy.
But like, people were saying like...
Oh yeah, the Japanese translation to all of that is just as bad.
If not, like, yeah.
And I was like, how?
And also the Chinese translation too, apparently.
The Japanese and the Chinese dialogue is like, very similar.
So I was like, oh.
So like, it's just a game.
It's just...
It's just how they do it, apparently.
It's the direction of the game.
So like, yeah, okay.
So now I know that...
Now I know where we're heading to.
AP93, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your very first super chat too.
Thank you so much.
Hi Toki.
It's my birthday today.
2024 was great, especially because I discovered you one year ago these days.
Cheers to an even better 2025.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat, AP.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear AP93.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Okay, wait, is that...
Oh, I thought that says Beijing.
And I was like, what?
There was a Beijing?
Back then?
I was like, that can't be right.
No, but...
I just can't read.
It's alright.
It's the story of my life.
I need to start selling some of these things.
Some of these are like, not great.
We'll get rid of this.
We have the general sword anyway.
So we'll get rid of all these guys.
I feel like none of these matters anyway.
Alright, get rid of the fists.
Oh, my fists are not that strong.
I really want to use blade and hoops, but like...
They're trash.
The DPS is trash.
Guys, I found...
I know I said this before, but like...
This game is 25 plus hours long.
So we're gonna be here for a while.
We're gonna...
We're gonna be here for a little bit, guys.
Alright.
Hello, Zhongfei.
Your brother tried to do stuff.
I don't know what happened, but like...
I blacked out.
Oh, not Doki.
Sounds like you've been busy lately.
But don't let your victories go to your head.
Get too comfortable, you might find yourself caught off guard.
Let me teach you a special trick of mine.
Keep your head on your shoulders and use it well.
I don't think Zhongfei was known to keep his head on his shoulders.
Zhongfei was definitely not known for that.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go...
I'm sorry, I love that.
These are like nothing, right?
These are just XP farm.
So I don't have to do any of these.
Oh, wait.
I need to unlock this.
Oh!
A maple horse?
Goodbye, horse.
I have a new friend now.
Goodbye.
You know what they say about horse meat, guys?
What do they say, Doki?
I don't know, ask Ikea.
No!
I don't wanna!
I don't even care, dude.
Oh my gosh, how else am I gonna see the funny people in my room?
Oh my god, I was getting drugged!
He's buying incense from this one guy?
This one mysterious guy that somehow disappeared?
Guys, I don't think this incense...
I knew it.
I knew I was getting fucking drugged by this innkeeper.
You have any leaves?
Yeah, this dealer!
I gotta find this fucking dealer right now.
I fucking knew it.
That's why I keep seeing this fucking child in my room.
I'm like, who is this child?
Where is his parents?
I stopped using the incense and Doki disappeared.
I fucking knew it.
Oh yeah, I forgot, left Doki.
Alright, give me a sec, it's been a while.
Goodbye, right Doki.
Hello, still right Doki.
Still right Doki.
Where did I put left Doki?
Oh, center Doki.
Doki from around the border.
Wait, oh there we go.
Doki from around the world.
Okay, we gotta find his dealer.
Also, how's the sound?
It's been a while since we looked into the sound.
So I hope everything is okay.
Okay, we gotta go.
It's over there.
There's where his dealer is.
It's right in this corner.
Hello.
The innkeeper sent me.
For some quote unquote incense.
Incense?
Oh, there's my sister.
You see the child too?
That's some strong shit.
Oh, she does not see the child.
Okay, nevermind.
Oh wait, you do!
Oh my god.
She's...
Or they're not real?
Wait, is she fake too?
She's not real?
Hello?
Little girl or little boy?
I can't tell you.
It's very hard to tell.
You're all just beautiful.
Okay, little boy.
How do you know?
Are you looking for her herbs?
Wait, are you the dealer?
Oh no, okay.
I'm definitely getting high.
Yeah, these visions.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
No, the innkeeper was joking me up.
Yeah, I was definitely getting drugged in the inn.
Oh my god.
I was sleeping to that incense too.
It's all out, so it's not good.
That is not good.
No wonder I was actually...
I was seeing things.
What's the accident faction you think Doki would choose?
The correct answer is Cao Cao.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Was this, you went to your home?
I think it might have been, yeah.
I don't know, I'm giving vague fucking choices.
It was either I don't know or I maybe.
I don't think the incense is...
is helping too.
What can I do to remember?
I might or might not know.
Why is this little boy fucking dealing with drugs?
I had to hazard a guess.
I'd say that you are suffering from some kind of formless malady.
And finding a cure for such a thing is beyond my current abilities.
This is quite humiliating and intriguing.
Would you mind if I traveled with you for a while until I find a cure?
I wish I could stop seeing people.
I can treat you if you are injured.
You're a doctor?
How old are you?
When did you get your...
I don't mind.
Why?
Do I just die and fight him?
Wait, does...
What if I just say no?
Like, where did you get your degree?
You're so young!
No, I don't want a child to be my doctor.
I...
What if I have...
What if I get an arrow through my fucking chest and then the little boy...
Wait, what?
Did he just invited himself?
He just invited himself.
I said no.
What if an arrow goes through my chest and then he was like, don't worry, smell this incense.
My name is...
Well, you can call me Yuan Hua.
Yuan Hua.
I am a surgeon.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay, accomplished a mission.
I don't know how.
I just talked to a guy.
Oh wait.
Vanquishing the bandits?
I don't remember if these are...
Do these actually grant me anything?
I don't remember.
Oh, it does.
Okay.
Yeah, the people grant me stuff.
I can't believe it.
Okay, I need to remember how to play this game, guys.
Guys, I need to remember how to play this game because I definitely do not.
Okay.
There's only two buttons.
Not gonna lie.
Nevermind.
I can remember.
There's literally only two buttons to remember.
Okay, technically three buttons to remember.
Okay, get over here.
What I do remember is that they're all tall.
They're all bigger than me.
I am a short king.
Here to represent all the short kings.
That's right.
No more diverse... wait, actually yes, diversity higher because they're all just tall people.
Allow short people to become generals!
We have feelings too!
We're just as good as the tall people.
We're just as good as you.
That's right.
Can a tall person do this?
Okay, there you go.
Jesus, how many fucking officers are there?
Exactly.
If you guys didn't know, Chow Chow is also a short king too.
How tall is he?
He's like incredibly short.
And look at that, he beat them all.
Okay, where's the last...
Okay, there he is.
Okay.
He was five foot one?!
Holy shit, he was fucking composite!
I like how the game made him so fucking tall compared to
like...
There he is.
I want to make sure...
Nice.
Jesus Christ, this guy is Wait, they still exist?
The yellow turban generals?
Oh shit.
Oh fuck, I forgot to do the RB fist.
I can't believe it!
I'm technically taller than him!
Oh my god!
He is the shortest of all short kings.
He is the role model to us all.
Oh nice, my proficiency increased.
I didn't even...
Oh shit, what?!
Okay, that should have...
Oh fuck.
Oh no, this is bad.
Jesus Christ, this guy is so strong.
I think this is the strongest one.
Nice.
Yay, I did it!
I did it!
No!
Yeah, this is mine now.
I own you.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I'm not gonna use the wheel though, because...
What's this?
Deliver a single slash and then move back quickly.
Okay.
Nice.
Bro forced you into this state with a funny instance, yet can't fix you from it.
Thank you for the super chat, Darkblade.
Thank you, thank you.
Is there like...
Ye olde Dynasty Rehab?
Guys, I'm a little worried now for my guy.
He's been sleeping with the incense for a very, very long time.
I'm a little bit worried for my guy right now.
I don't think he's okay anymore.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here you go.
I found your dealer.
Thank you, my esteemed guest.
You're the one who found the herb- oh yes.
We call him the herb seller.
Yes.
Now I won't have to worry about running- You're still gonna put that in my room?!
He literally told you that it causes visions!
And you're gonna put it in my room?!
Still?!
Oh yes, you have received another letter from a distinguished individual.
I left it in your room.
Please find a moment to read it later.
Like, excuse me?!
Are we done?
You're still gonna- Oh, it's fucked.
It's actually fucked.
Okay.
Oh, it just goes automatically.
Okay, nevermind.
I thought it gives me a choice.
Alright, I didn't win one.
This will be fast anyway, right?
Oh shit, oh shit!
Whoops!
I sorta missed.
That's okay.
These will be fast, don't worry.
This will be really fast.
Oh, I didn't wanna do this one.
I feel like these ones are, like, useless.
I can't believe it won't let me, like, pick.
Click double confirm.
Get out of here.
You don't matter.
You're just little guys.
I'm here for the big boy.
The biggest of boys.
Where are they?
Where are the biggest of boys?
Oh, there they are.
Holy shit!
He's so big!
Alright, good.
Okay, oh shit.
It's fine.
I deflected it.
That's fine.
I didn't deflect that very well, but that's okay.
I deflected it.
Oh my god, these guys are such a waste of time.
You don't matter.
You don't even have a name.
You're literally a just-caught bandit chief.
Come on, get up.
Oh, I completed the training.
Nice.
Okay.
Come on, get out!
Get out!
Get out here!
You no-name man!
Okay, nice.
Oh shit, not nice.
Okay.
Oh shit, nice.
Alright, yay!
Yay!
That's right!
I'm gonna dance on your grave.
Oh, I do.
Nice.
Okay, I need that actually.
I need skill points to upgrade my man.
Okay, those are- I just need to talk to the people.
The people are the ones that give me stuff, but I want to see who sent me a letter.
Oh my god.
Yo, dragons.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fun fact, it took 21 years for the Yellow Turban Rebellion to end completely.
He's just gonna live in my room like that?
Bro, take off your shoes.
Fucking rude!
That's so rude.
He doesn't even take off his shoes!
He's like- Oh my god, I already hate him.
The disrespect.
Alright.
Oh, I got two.
Two guys sent me letters.
To all who fight for peace.
Lian province is in turmoil.
Han Sui has joined the invading Qi'an forces in rebelling against the Emperor.
All who fight for peace are ordered to gather in Lian.
Join the government forces led by General Dong Zhuo to rid the land of this festering evil.
Rise for the Emperor!
Rise for peace!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
And then I have a letter from...
Route A- Route Z, I think.
Dear Natoki, I hope you have been in good health since the decisive battle against the Yellow Turbans.
I'm writing to you for one reason alone.
I need your help to put some rebels in their place.
I'll tell you more when we meet.
If you're willing to lend us your strength, please, make the journey to Changsha in Jing province.
Oh, he wants me, guys.
Guys, I'm in.
Guys, I'm gonna add another guy to my collection.
Another general to my collection.
And then I'm bringing a third guy with me.
Alright.
Let's get this item real quick, though.
Recommended level.
Oh, I'm level 12.
I should be fine.
I get a horn.
Gah!
Alright.
How many generals are we collecting?
I don't even know anymore.
I...
I don't...
I don't even know how many generals I have anymore.
How the fuck do I...
Oh, it's this area.
The world where I... Guys, remember this area?
Where I got incredibly lost?
You guys remember that?
Hahaha.
Where you apparently have to use your fucking horse to get over there?
Okay.
I gotta go this way.
Okay, how do I get up?
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, there's a ramp over here.
Wait, reinforcements?
Excuse me?
What do you mean reinforcements?
You...
How do you slap people?
The rebellion!
I killed your leader!
He was so hot though.
I understand why you would...
I feel like a lot of cult leaders, like the requirement to become a cult leader is just to be hot.
Like...
Hahaha.
I feel like that's like a majority of like cult leaders.
They just gotta be like hot and like very charismatic.
So it makes you wanna like donate hundreds and thousands of dollars.
Anyway guys, thank you so much for...
Hahaha.
Haha.
I feel like streamers can technically become cult leaders.
Um, if like we can use our powers.
Like, I feel like... Okay, not gonna lie.
I feel like... Okay.
I feel like it's very easy for streamers to become a cult leader.
But like...
But also like, that's so much work.
Like...
No, no, no.
We're not cult.
My mission is to create an actual religion.
Hahaha.
Why be a cult when I can be a registered religion for tax breaks?
Um...
Okay.
Are we not done?
Where's D?
Where is D?
The fuck?
Oh, it's over there.
The advisor.
Oh my god, it's the nerd that still lives?
Alright, nice.
Alright, get out of here, nerd.
Get out of here.
I'm gonna stuff you in the goddamn locker.
Get over here.
That's right.
Locker time for you, nerd.
For tax reasons, we are a religion.
Duck, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rising, thank you for the superchat.
Ah yes, I'm a doctor.
Let me stay with you for free room and food and I'll totally take care of you.
By the way, this doctor was the one that started all of this too.
Wait, there's more?
How many fucking people are there?
How do I get out of here?
Okay.
Get my horse here.
Get my maple horse here.
Alright, cheer.
Cheer up.
Dash.
Come on.
Get over here.
Wait.
Sorry, I forgot where RB was.
I was pressing every button because I forgot.
Right button is where RB was.
I was literally pressing everything but right button.
I was like, oh, it's the left side, right?
That's what right button means.
It's on the left.
Juan George, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
We're gonna aim to be a registered religion.
I just need a place to worship.
That's really it.
That's the one thing that's holding me back.
Come on.
Get- Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Jesus Christ, he's huge.
It doesn't matter.
Fucking rise up.
Nice.
Oh my god, why is he so fucking tanky though?
Jesus Christ.
He's just so tanky.
You're like an- You're literally an NPC.
How are you so tanky?
I don't understand.
Alright, get out of here.
Get out of here.
That's- Oh, shit.
That's fucking right.
Leave.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh!
Whoops.
Didn't realize he was in the middle of an ult there.
Yeah, it'd be very awkward if I died to an NPC and it wasn't even Lu Bu in the end.
Also, I'm scared.
I'm really scared to fight Lu Bu.
It feels like this game is a lot harder now.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're not a cult, by the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rozin, thank you for the super chat.
What do you mean?
This is definitely not a cult where I spend lots of money.
Wait.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gus, thank you for the magenta sofa.
The church of the blood god is not a cult.
Exactly!
As long as you have the church of something, it can't be a cult.
Thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you, thank you.
Restores 10% when victory has been achieved in an ally.
Wait, that's good.
Right?
Okay, boost health by 20%.
Boost health by 3%.
Restores health.
I feel like I rather just have boost health by 20%.
I'll just have that for now.
I'm gonna go all the way back.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, it's just my house.
Okay.
Wait, I have two areas.
I have two areas to go to.
Oh my god, they're offering me stuff!
Oh my god, Birch?!
Okay, who's Birch?
I'm sorry, I'm done playing with you now.
Now my horse is even cooler.
Okay, do I wanna do Huang Gai or Dong Zhuo?
I'll go this way.
Let's go this way.
Oh, weapon shop.
Is it better?
No.
Wait, what's better?
No, it's the same.
Okay, I already have... Wait, what?
Three, three?
Yeah, they're all the same.
You're welcome.
Is there more stuff here?
Oh, they're literally all the same.
Wait, no.
This is new.
The battle gauntlets rank 80.
Because...
Oh my god, I'm broke though.
I'm so poor.
I can't buy it.
I'm too poor.
What's this?
Suppression of the end.
Oh no, this is the Dong Zhuo!
The Dong Zhuo level.
Okay, let's unlock this fast travel.
Wait, Birch is the best horse before post-game?
Just keep it equipped and level up?
But what about the red hair?
Can I not...
Can I not kidnap...
Lu Bu's horse?
That can't be.
Shouldn't the red hair be even stronger?
Oh, red hair is post-game?
I can't believe it.
What is the fucking horse gonna do when I kill his master?
Is he just gonna retire?
I'm gonna kill him anyway.
Let me fucking steal the horse.
Oh,
Guan Yun gets it.
It'll be a shame if he loses his head.
Don't worry.
This weapon is sharp enough to cut somebody's head off.
I'm listening.
He's like, listen.
I'm like, waiting.
I'm like, okay.
When does he start talking?
I'm eating my snack.
You need only to obey my orders.
Ignore anything Zhang Wei says.
If I die, nobody will be sending out orders and that will lead to a catastrophe.
Remember that.
Doki is too lazy to be a cult leader?
I just feel like...
It's so much work.
I don't know.
It just feels like more work than it should be.
We'll start by attacking the enemy's headquarters.
If I could delegate being a cult leader, maybe I'll give it.
I don't mind being the face of it.
If I can delegate parts of it.
I wonder if that's how pyramid schemes work.
I mean, that's basically it.
I'd rather start a pyramid scheme than a cult.
Because that's where you can delegate it to people more.
It's practically a cult.
What should I do?
You're more useful that way.
Oh, I can do whatever the fuck I want.
I feel like you earn more in a pyramid scheme too.
If you're the head of the pyramid scheme, because all the money goes back to you.
It's practically just the same.
It's practically just the same as a cult.
Except it's not a registered religion, so you don't get tax breaks, which is a downside.
Being in a pyramid scheme versus being a cult.
Wait, are some cults registered religions?
Cults that are registered religions.
Guys, this is all hypothetical, by the way.
Oh yeah, Scientology is.
I forgot.
Scientology is a registered religion.
I feel like if I was ever to start a cult...
What the fuck is Church of Universal and Triumph?
The fuck is that?
Founded in the United States in 1975.
I don't think that...
If a religion was found in 1975, I don't know if that's a natural religion.
Don't look it up.
I just think...
I just think it's weird that...
I'm not gonna talk about Scientology.
I'm a little...
Too many...
The thing I'm like, really...
I don't know how they do it, but they have celebrities in Scientology.
How the fuck did they do that?
That's actually crazy.
If I were to ever start a registered religion, I hope it goes... I'm sorry.
I...
I hope...
I hope it's just as good as Scientology.
Doki, please.
Doki, no.
The Family International.
Why are they all found in the 70s?
The Family International is founded in 1968.
What the fuck?
What is their lore?
What is...
Okay, so apparently, we already all like founded in 1955.
19... Wait.
Oh no, that's the one where they all drink the Kool-Aid.
Okay, 1974, 1955, 1968.
Oh man, the 70s were fucking weird.
The 70s were fucking weird.
Oh my god.
What the fuck was going on in the 70s?
What?
Born too late to create a successful cult god.
Damn it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, I was looking up like...
Cults that are registered religions and like...
Let's see.
And it's like...
1, 2, 3...
Wait, Mormonism?
I'm not touching that.
Wait, why is Mormonism...
Is it...
Okay.
Anyway, 1, 2, 3...
Oh.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 5, 6, 6 out of like...
3, 6, 6 out of the 9 things, the 9 searches, cults, quote unquote cults, started in the 70s.
That registered religion.
Like, the fuck?
So many choices.
Oh my god.
Which one to choose?
God damn it, I was born too late to be...
To get on the craze, the cult craze.
Blazing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do we get a special quote later when we join the cult?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Simple minded.
Oh yeah, right, right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
GloryCrosses, thank you for the AkaSupa.
Can I bribe, I mean donate to secure a leadership position?
Thank you for the AkaSupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Oh, this is like pay to win.
Pay to become a leader.
Pay to become a... What is it called?
Like, the thing about cults is that they have like weird fucking names for their positions.
What was like the name for like the Scientology leader?
We'll go to the bottom left.
Pay to win cult simulator.
I know there was like the Grand Wizard, right?
No, that's a different thing.
No, it was not.
Was it actually the Grand Wizard?
Oh my god.
No, that's a different thing.
No, that is... I'm sorry.
That is absolutely...
No, that's something else.
Okay, but what was the...
Oh, please Scientologist, I'm sorry.
I confused your positions.
I'm so sorry.
Please, please Scientologist lawyers, please.
Wait, so like...
So like, what were the positions...
What was the leader called in Scientology?
Okay, we'll get this guy.
They use codenames?
What were they called?
Oh shit.
They were just called a Scientist?
What degree do they have?
Are they legally allowed to call themselves Scientists?
Oh shit.
I'm trying my best.
I'm literally trying my best to defend this camp.
What do you mean?
I'm literally here!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
You know what?
You're right.
He's right.
Why am I saving them?
They have their own navy?
Oh my god.
I want to buy sea land.
Sorry, I was like thinking...
You guys said they have their own navy?
I wonder like, how much would it cost to buy sea land?
Honestly.
I feel like I could crowdfund that.
They're known as like the smallest country in the world.
Oh, quote unquote country.
Oh my god, I remembered I wanted to look up on how to get knighted.
I see that.
Wait, guys.
Would you guys judge me if I used my super chat earnings to get knighted?
By sea land?
Would you guys judge me if I...
So I can be like...
What was it?
Lady Doki?
Wait, I can buy land on sea land too.
Is it like the stock market?
If I buy enough land, I'll legally own sea land?
Is that even a thing?
Yeah, because sea land is like...
It was basically a British, quote unquote colony in the sea.
Which is like a British sea base.
And then the family that owned the sea base was like, I declare independence!
Even though they're nearly at justice.
They're a sea base too.
So like...
Yeah, it was a British fort and then the family that owned it was like, you know what?
We're gonna be our own country.
Even though like, I don't know how that's fucking possible.
But like, I wonder if it's like the stock market where if I buy enough territory off of sea land, I'll just legally own it.
Oh my god!
Did he come back?!
Oh my god.
I was trying to go help.
No, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you!
I'd judge you if you didn't use the super chat to get united!
Also, wheels are cracked in this game.
They are considered top three best weapons.
So if you love them, go to town.
I love the wheel weapon.
But like, I don't have a strong enough wheel.
The sword is like 90, so like...
I'm just using the sword just cause...
Oh yeah, just cause it's at like 80.
For the... to cheer up.
Alright.
That's fine.
I just wanna screw up with British one more time.
Nice, I did it.
I did it, guys!
No need to...
That's right!
I'm a hero!
I did it, guys!
No need to thank me!
Wait, what is the strongest weapon in this game?
It doesn't get stronger.
You have to like, find them.
Okay.
Wait, did they kill everybody?
Did you guys do it?
I nearly saved your life!
Damn!
First time...
That's a politician.
Wait, first time...
working with a politician?
Like...
Really?
Nah, bro.
That's basically like...
a lot of...
the rest of the world.
Wait, he came back?
Sounds about right, yeah.
Wait, I can get knighted in Ireland?
What if I just get knighted...
knighted like, in all the British colonies?
Like, ex-British colonies...
Sorry, Ireland's not British, but like...
in all the British territory.
Or like, ex-British territory.
Wait, I can?
I can just get knighted everywhere?
Oh my god, guys, would you judge me if I...
Wait, can I get knighted in Canada?
Wait, I can get knighted in Canada?
Okay, look.
As soon as I kill you, I need to figure out how I can get knighted in Canada.
Wait, I wanna get...
What if I...
What if I just get knighted in Canada, guys?
I will if you don't.
Oh my god.
Wait, who's gonna knight me?
Like...
Wait a minute, but we...
We don't even have...
We have a problem.
Okay, no, we kicked him out.
Just because you can doesn't mean you shit.
But that means...
I could be the first VTuber to get knighted.
Guys...
Think about the dexterity article they're gonna write about me.
Think about it.
Think about the dexterity...
It's good publicity.
It's a business investment.
Oh my god, I could like...
When I buy my knighthood, I could like...
I could actually just use it as a...
Tax write-off.
As a business...
It could be...
It could actually just be my...
Business expense.
Yes, I did it.
True, cause it was for content.
It was literally for my business.
Okay, we gotta go that way now.
Oh my god.
I'm so smart.
I'm actually a ruthless business woman.
Oh my god!
I'll just do an outfit reveal of a Nikon outfit and then be like...
Guys, as an official knighted...
This is now a business expense.
No way, that's genius.
Wait, nobles sell their...
Wait, nobles sell their titles?
Alright, it's time.
Let's go!
For Doki!
Oh my god, I could actually...
Okay, okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's so awkward.
Wait, that's not fair!
How come they could do that And I couldn't!
Why were they able to do that?
Oh my god, wait.
They're so strong.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Why could they do that and I couldn't do that?
Okay, but then...
Okay guys, the reason why Elton John can be knighted is because he's literally Elton John.
The only thing I cannot get is like...
Oh shit.
I wonder if a Shiro would ever get knighted.
Can you imagine?
If like...
Oh my god, what's his name?
What is the name of like...
Cause like...
Oh my god, who's the king again?
Charles?
Queen Elizabeth has been my queen for so long.
Like, I don't even...
I don't even know what his name is.
Not my king!
It's Charles, right?
What is Charles' kid's kid called?
Guys.
I can actually...
Not gonna lie.
I can see...
Hashtag not my king.
William?
No, no.
Charles' kid's kid.
So like...
Not the other...
Not Princess Diana's...
I like how I remember Princess Diana.
Not...
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
This nerd's gonna beat me up with his hands.
Is it George?
Okay.
I can see George...
Knighting his favorite streamer.
I...
I can't...
I can't... Not gonna lie.
I can see like...
George growing up to his favorite streamer.
And then like...
He's like...
Whoever he is...
I can see him knight.
Wait, George can't become king?
Yes he can.
Isn't he like the first...
The first point of...
Of the other king?
Of the other child?
Of the other... Princess Diana's kid?
William?
I don't know how the royalty works.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, the first point of William.
He should be king next.
After William dies.
Yes.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I can see...
Whenever George becomes king...
He's gonna like...
Knight his favorite streamer.
He's like...
You know...
A lot of like...
People in position of power...
Kids...
Are fans of streamers now.
And a lot like...
You know how like...
A lot of celebrity kids...
Are collaborating with streamers.
Because they're like...
My dad's famous.
Or my mom's famous.
So you should collaborate with me.
To their favorite streamers.
And obviously they're like...
Oh my god.
Your dad slash mom is this celebrity.
I feel like...
Eventually we're gonna hit the stage...
Where a streamer's gonna be knighted.
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for Dokia.
Thank you.
You think Dokia's ego sucking goes too hard now?
Wait till she gets knighted.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Any celebrity children watching me?
Any celebrity kids?
Okay, and then we'll go here.
I should really read what I just upgraded.
Um...
Guys, come on.
I must have a famous celebrity child watching me, right?
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Dokia.
Oh my god, thank you so much.
Wait, can I just get a certificate?
Oh, that sounds very...
Oh yeah, I was gonna say that does not sound like the best place to live.
Sounds like Louisiana.
What the fuck is going on in Louisiana?
Louisiana?
I don't know about Detroit, but Louisiana?
Okay, everything happens in Detroit.
No, I feel like...
Okay, anarchy works.
It's fun after like a day or two.
But then like...
But then...
I think anarchy is fun after a day or two.
But then it's like post-anarchy.
You know like...
Post-anarchy...
Clarity?
And then you're just like...
Oh, maybe it's not that.
Post-anarchy clarity.
Hmm.
Yeah, but he just wants to be the king of everything.
Or the emperor.
Damn.
Wow.
What conversation?
I said one word.
This conversation is going on too long.
I'm like, okay.
I said one word.
How dare you interrupt my thought process.
Too long.
Be off with you.
I need someone that doesn't talk back.
Alright, let's go grab our gifts.
I got a battler.
I got an old coin.
Okay, nice.
I'm talking to you.
Not with you.
Okay.
Gah!
I'm not going to do any of the other side quests.
Zacona, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just finished my fourth semester.
And now I'm going for an interview tomorrow.
For an internship at a five-star hotel.
I think I'm going to die from stress.
Pray for me, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good luck with your interview.
Oh my god, it's going to be crazy.
Working at a hotel.
The shit you're going to see.
There's a lot of crazy hotel stories, too.
I used to watch...
Was it Hotel Babylon?
I don't know if you guys ever read the Babylon series.
A hotel Babylon.
There was an airline Babylon.
And shit like that.
Where they grab interviews.
And stories from people who worked at hotels.
And worked at airlines.
And stuff like that.
Hotel Babylon was freaking crazy.
I wish they never cancelled that show.
That was such a good show.
And you're going to see a lot of crazy stories.
Especially five-star hotels.
Because people who work that money.
Who work...
Wait, defeat Xiaohu Yun?
What the fuck?
Wait, why am I...
Wait, why am I killing Xiaohu Yun?
Oh shit!
Wait, why am I...
Why am I attacking Tao Tao's generals?
I feel like...
Especially the mega rich people.
They do some...
They're so rich.
That they're bored with regular mundane stuff.
That they do crazy...
For the mega super rich.
They're like...
They can do anything now.
They just do really fucked up shit.
I like to be like...
To feel the thrill.
I didn't pay attention.
I just saw...
Upgrade and I was like...
Oh, upgrade!
Oh shit, where's my horse?
It disappeared.
I need to jump over here.
How do I jump with my horse again?
Oh well, I'll just go down here.
Hello?
Oh wait.
Eh, Shao Chun.
When will they shoot an arrow in your eye?
Get him.
Get this nerd.
Not so wise now.
Shouldn't have gone to the battlefield you fucking nerd.
Get out.
Oh wait, there's another guy here.
That's fucking right.
I feel like a lot of...
Oh shit.
I feel like...
I mean, even Bill Gates is insane.
I was like...
No, Bill Gates!
I thought you were just like...
A fucking nerd!
Like a grandpa nerd!
But then I found out Bill Gates is fucking wild.
Like...
He's fucking wild!
And then I'm like thinking like...
If Bill Gates can do that and he's like...
What, 80?
What the fuck is Warren Buffet doing?
Oh my god!
Freaky Gates.
What did he do?
I'm not gonna say it.
It's actually pretty freaky.
I was like...
Oh my god!
What the fuck does Warren Buffet do?
If anything, Warren Buffet is actually like...
Some actual grandpa.
Okay, I'm just gonna go straight to...
Cause like the mission is just to kill Xiaohu Yuan, right?
Defeat... Okay, yeah.
Oh my god, get out!
Get out!
Send me through!
Okay, there you go.
There you are.
Oh shit.
God, he sounds so weird.
Sounding like a regular guy.
Get out of here.
That's fucking right.
I broke your guard.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
I know two buttons!
And that's all the buttons I need to know!
Okay, I need to block this and take...
Where's the jar?
Oh, there you are.
Wait, what?
What does the jar do then?
I thought the jar was musou.
No, the musou is alcohol.
Get over here.
Yes it is!
Oh shit, oh nice.
Counter.
That's fucking right.
Get over here!
Oh fuck.
That's right, I have four bread.
Oh, I have three bread.
Oh fuck!
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no!
He's almost dead, don't worry!
Live a little longer!
He's almost dead, I almost got him!
I almost got him!
Just live a little longer, guys!
Oh no.
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
We did it.
It's over.
I'm losing.
Pulls out a bow.
Ye olde medieval gun.
Pulls out the ye olde medieval gun.
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
Okay, nice.
Increases mounted stability.
Okay, so I just have to level up Birch.
He's actually the strongest horse in this game.
Abso, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
How has your day been?
This conversation has gone on too long.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Increases the vitality.
Restores health by... Oh wait, what?
Wait, that's...
Wait, also like... I have better strikes?
What's this?
Okay, I don't think I need the mad dash or whatever the fuck.
Uh, attack while in the sand will unleash a shockwave and go airborne.
World wind kick, mad blade rush catching enemies and then okay, I think I'll try a mad blade rush for this.
Uh... what did I see I wanted to try out... what's accessories?
Boost attack.
It was like 70% or some sh- Okay, it's not any of these.
Okay, never mind.
Do I have anything better?
Or is this like my best weapon?
Yeah, this is actually my best weapon.
I don't have enough money to buy better weapons yet.
Ah!
Oh, there's an item.
Item!
Oh, who's this old man?
Hello?
Take this.
I hope it'll serve you well.
Oh, thank you, old man.
Okay, cool.
Thank you, old man.
I appreciate it.
What is this?
Oh, I'm too low level.
Oh wait, what's this?
Is that fan mail?
Oh, I don't have fan mail.
No one wants to talk to me.
Is the spear better than the sword, guys?
Or which is better?
The gauntlets or the spear?
Or should I- Actually, I'm gonna save.
Never mind.
I'm gonna save until I can afford a strong loopy loop.
Oh, no.
All the old goons died.
No!
Neo Dynasty goons all died in war and I killed them.
I killed- Oh, shit!
Okay.
Wait, that's 80.
Wait, that's what we need.
Okay, it's time to sell.
Oh, no.
I'm so broke.
Okay, I'm gonna sell the weapons I have that are useless.
Okay, 42.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I don't.
I'm so poor.
Oh, no.
And I killed them, too.
It was me.
Wait, I just need to sell one more.
Uh, I'll sell this.
Okay, I should have- Okay, I should be able to afford the crimson orchids.
Which normal attack?
Okay, these are like the strong ones.
Yes.
Uh, whirlwind kick, palm strike.
Okay, that should be everything, right?
Whirlwind kick.
The counter has attack while in the sanctuary will unleash a shockwave.
Okay, I'd rather have that.
And then... yeah, all right.
Wait, why can I still talk here?
I already looked at all the new weapons.
Oh, the shittier new weapons.
Okay, Hong Gai.
I'm ready for Route H.
Sun Jian Headquarters.
You can beat a high level side battle.
I believe, Doki.
You see, I could, but then I'm wasting my time.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I want you to help us take care of some bandits.
We have an entire army.
Your family's literally rich.
This is one of his responsibilities.
Oh husband, you bought too expensive meal and now we're homeless.
But having you with us really tips the scales in our favor.
Hong Gai, I have something I want to ask you.
Oh my god, is that Sun Qian Qian?
Sorry, I can't pronounce your name.
I'm not Doki.
This is the warrior who had all of our backs during the battle with the yellow turbans.
She's so different.
She looks so different.
She's like more woman.
You're supposed to be a child right now.
Okay, in the beginning, she used to be more... yeah, I was like, she's supposed to be 12.
I was like...
Okay, um...
In the beginning of the games, she was more tomboy.
She was like really like tomboy coded.
But then like as the game progressed, she got like more and more less...
Yes, tomboy erasured.
Like we are experiencing tomboy eraser right now.
They're erasing all tomboy.
What brings you here?
Terrible.
Dude, your assassination 10 games ago.
In the making.
I think she's wearing armor, you know.
Except for the middle of her chest.
I could just get a sword and go...
Her voice even got higher.
The jade is really strong.
Yeah, like in the beginning of the games, she was like very tomboy coded.
Like even her voice was lower and everything.
Okay, Sun Jian's forces versus Wuxian's forces.
Uh...
12king, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun fact, historically Sun Xianxian is at most...
Yeah, I was gonna be like, are you supposed to be a fucking child right now?
What are you doing?
Who let this child at the battlefield?
Like...
She can be the strongest child.
At least she's wearing shorts underneath that dress.
No child label.
You're right, her father.
I mean her dad beats up tigers.
It is our hope that you can achieve similar results in our service.
But it wouldn't be right to put all the pressure on you.
That's why you and I will be working together.
Oh, together.
I think it would be better if I went with you.
Excuse me, Sun Xianxian?
How dare you interfere?
It seems Shang Xiang has taken a liking to you.
Oh, please no.
No, no, that's illegal.
Oh, please.
Oh, no, no, Sun Xianxian.
Oh, wait a minute.
No, no, FBI.
I said no.
Let's move on to the middle, shall we?
You have a bunch of guys.
Just like, I don't know, a guy who's been a warrior for most of his life or a literal child.
I don't know who I want to fight with, guys.
A faction that rejects the legitimacy of the rule of the Han has risen up in Shang Xiang.
We've been given a task of quelling the rebellion.
The rebels follow Wu Xian, who I'm told is a former bandit leader.
Defeating him will bring a swift end to the uprising.
I'll command all our forces personally.
To do so, I plan to start the battle by assessing the situation from our headquarters.
The correct choice is to go alone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ever since the Lu Bei marriage subplot, they've ruined the tomboy.
No!
My lord, my tomboy eraser.
Does this mean that you expect some unforeseen threats from the enemy?
I do.
Ou Xing's forces are lying in wait in their own stronghold.
We should assume that they have set traps for us.
Right.
Judging by the Terran, I'd say ambushes are likely.
But there are so many places they could be hiding.
You can't possibly guess where they'll come from.
Which is why...
we should proceed as carefully as possible.
Our top priority would be to maintain an even advance as we push the front line.
Luckily, we have a reliable ally for this fight.
Not Doki, I want you to keep an eye on how the battle plays out and go wherever you are needed.
You're short of hands, Not Doki.
Then allow me to join you.
You need butt ass before we leave for battle.
I think... Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, child.
You stay.
No, no, it's okay.
Come tell me when... No, it's okay, child.
No, no, no.
The adults are talking right now.
The adults are talking.
You can now select... Do I want a child?
Or...
Which one should... I like how they put a child... the child in as my main choice.
They're like, come on.
Go alone.
Or should I just go alone?
Guys, take the five-year-old child.
Do I take a general that's been in many, many wars?
Or should I... Let's just... You know, you're right.
You're right, guys.
Let me... Let me bring the child to her first war.
All right, let's bring... Let's bring... Let's show this child her first war.
Bring your kids a work day.
It's their first one.
Let's go.
Oh my god, they have the high ground?
Oh no, not the high ground.
Oh shit.
How is morale already falling?
We literally just started the war!
Okay, let's grab him out of here.
Nice.
Nice, we did it.
Push the ambush.
I'll get this one first.
Get over here.
You brought a child instead of a war god.
That might... That might be what's lowering morale right now.
You guys told me to bring her!
How is it my fault when I was just listening to you guys?
If anything, it's all... Both are false.
We both fucked up, guys.
He said go.
Oh, that's not... No, no, no, no, no.
I saw more people said take the child.
I... I saw you said take the child.
All right.
Come on, get over here.
Where the fuck is my...
Where the fuck is Xu Shanshan?
Where's she going?
Why is she not helping me?
Okay, the fight's almost over, but thanks for joining the war.
I should have brought the old man.
I should have.
Why did I bring... Why did I bring a child?
All right, nice.
All right, Xu Shanshan.
Oh shit, I keep accidentally getting off my horse.
Okay, we have to...
We have to go to the other side.
She's trying to learn, Doki.
How do I jump?
Guys, I don't remember how to jump on my horse.
Like, I'm stuck here.
I'm stuck in the farm.
Guys, guys, how do I jump?
I'm stuck on my farm.
Oh, never mind.
I figured it out.
The farm has stopped, Doki.
Who would win?
One tiny fence or...
Or a decorated war general.
Let's get him out of the way.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, come on.
Stop!
This is not fun anymore.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I'm stronger.
Oh, yeah?
You thought you got me?
Get counter-attacked.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
I did it.
No need to thank me.
Okay, we just gotta get this fort, too.
The fence of war.
That's right.
Get out of here.
What if I just go straight to the big boy?
No, I feel like Xinjiang's gonna actually die if I do that.
So like, I feel like the more generals I defeat, the more upgrades I get, right guys?
Is that true?
If I don't rush straight to the main boss, do I get like, uh...
Do I get more XP by killing the mini bo- guys?
Okay, let's get him out of here.
Yeah?
Okay.
All right, then I'll keep killing the mini generals.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Oh shit, no!
Oh, that's scary.
I didn't see the red.
Nice.
Get out of here.
My fort now.
I feel like she's useless.
Not gonna lie.
I don't know.
I have a feeling she feels a little useless.
I don't wonder why.
Okay, but she was bragging, okay?
She was like, um, I am a warrior princess and like, um...
Yeah, I'm pretty strong, says an eight-year-old to my face.
Okay, let's get her out of the way.
Uh, Cosmo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Sunshan- Sunshan Shen needs to complete her apprenticeship.
Ow, okay.
Okay, nice.
Easy.
And why did you believe- I don't know!
Because she's royalty?
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Wait, what the fuck?
Why is there like 200 men out here?
I didn't think she would lie to me like that.
Like, where are they going?
Where are you guys running to?
Hello?
Oh shit, they're all running to Sunshan!
Oh, that's a lot of peoples.
Okay, what if I do this?
Nice.
We've got them right where we want them.
Now...
Where is he taking- where are they taking him?
Oh my god, they're following him!
Oh my god, look at him go!
Look at him go!
Get him!
He's got this, he can take them on.
I believe in him.
Where are they taking him?
I know he's taking him to an ambush, but like...
What's gonna happen?
Oh, just one guy?
How is that- There's 20 of them!
There's 20 generals!
Like- Guys, this is a- You know, when you said you had an ambush coming, I thought you'd bring more people.
You brought 20 guys.
Like- He literally- He brought 20 guys and was like, Guys, don't worry, I got an ambush.
Don't worry.
It's okay, it's soon.
You are a beast.
Okay.
Go!
Oh yeah, it wasn't like- I just literally killed all of them.
In the back.
It's not like I did that, guys.
Thanks, guys.
No, no.
It's all Soonhae.
Good for him.
Good for Soonhae.
You know?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, we should get this guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's not me, guys.
It wasn't me.
Oh, except for this one guy.
What is this one guy doing here?
Okay, I'm gonna get back this.
Nice.
My turn!
That's fucking right.
Okay, they might have the other force, but we got this fort.
This will be ours.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Get chopped!
Come on!
Get out of here!
You might have a name!
Thank you, Soonhae, for carrying Doki.
Thank you for the Saka-Supa technique.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now a guy with no name.
Who's gonna win?
Oh my god, you know what?
No, I believe in Soonhae.
Let's just watch this.
I believe in this child.
Let's go help.
Let's go see how she does.
No, look!
Look!
She's doing it!
Look at that!
Go, child!
Go!
You got this!
Come on!
She's so dead!
Yeah!
Look at that!
She did it.
She did it, guys.
No name general lost to a child.
Look at that.
Yay, child!
Okay, not like that, guys.
Not like that, though, guys.
Not like that.
Save Soonjin right now.
I'll take the no name.
I'll kill the no name general and then you get the guy that actually is a threat.
Okay.
Let's 3v1 this.
There's no way we could lose.
We're literally 3v1ing.
How could we lose this?
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Come on.
You're so close to dying.
You don't even have an actual model.
Your model is default general 3.
Okay, nice.
My base now.
Alright, now we just need to...
Go!
Freedom!
Okay.
Let's cheer.
Come on.
Go, Birch, go!
Go!
With power and motivation!
Go, Birch, go!
Come on!
Motivating!
Okay.
All your...
Okay, so I think you have no...
You actually have no choice in that matter.
You might as well just...
Just give up now.
I have...
All I'm saying is that...
OH SHIT!
OH MY GOD!
He fucking grabbed me!
But all I'm saying is that maybe if you also recruited...
Okay, I shouldn't say that.
It did change the title more.
That's all I'm saying.
Alright, nice.
My base now.
Yeah!
We did it, guys!
We did it!
Can't argue with ourselves!
We stopped the rebellion!
Alright, we gotta level up our wheels.
Throw your wheels upward after a set amount of time.
They will fall from above and...
Jesus Christ!
Don't look up!
Eh...
Oh, I almost unlocked a new skill.
Oh, Birch!
You're gonna get stronger soon, Birch!
Wait, there's rage mode?
Wait a minute, how do I get into rage mode again?
I don't remember how to get into rage...
Oh, it's when I press the two buttons together!
Okay, wait.
I remember now.
JK, I remember.
Uh...
Let's see...
This is the position when you activate eyes.
Okay.
Nevermind, I remember now.
I almost forgot how to get into God of War mode.
Hello?
Hey, guys!
We did it!
We won with a coughing baby!
We're like, you know...
We'll wait a week until another rebellion shows up.
You know, during the Three Kingdoms era, it was not really considered peaceful.
Oh, thanks guys!
I mean, yeah.
I did kill 90% of the people there.
But yeah, no, credit the warrior princess!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Credit her!
Who only killed one guy.
I don't have that luxury.
I'm sorry, Miss Warrior Princess who descended from royalty.
You see, you fight as a hobby.
I get paid to fight.
You're right.
Of course not.
I wish I'd had that same mentality from the start.
I've always approached battles seriously.
And yet...
I'm still finding it difficult to keep my composure.
You're right!
Sorry.
Every single arrow...
is aiming.
Oh shit, sorry.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Like fear in a child?
Please, no!
Wait!
I was a bit...
No, we are not worried about her.
We were not worried about her, guys.
We're not.
Man, this sucks.
You're just going to get married off later.
I look forward to see...
I'm worried about...
No, we are not worried about her.
We're not worried about her.
That's not supposed to be anything flirtatious!
I was just motivating you!
Don't giggle at me!
Oh my god.
Okay, weapon shop.
Oh, it's the same thing.
I already have all of this.
Oh wait, I have letters.
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why is he...
I keep forgetting he exists.
Like...
What's happening?
He's just like...
Beside me or some shit.
I hate forgetting about it.
I already forgot about this guy's existence.
In this game.
Alright.
Oh, he sent me a letter.
You're next to me!
Why did you send me a letter?
You just...
Talked to me!
Not jokey.
Excuse me for being...
It's like when someone texts you...
And they're sitting next to you.
And they text you about your life.
Hey, can you do the dishes?
But what exactly...
Is your relationship with the princess?
Oh my god!
She's a child!
We are the princess!
We would climb...
Any mountain...
For her and...
Oh my god, it's her!
Oh my god, it's her sims!
We would climb any mountain...
For her and any river...
And charge across any battlefield...
To watch over and support her.
Just because you're a little more suave than us...
Doesn't mean...
You can get ahead so easily.
I just said good luck!
I...
Besides...
When men like her brother and lord joe urm...
The princess is used to good looking fellas.
Or should be.
Or she should be.
Anyway, if we wish to join our cadre...
Then take this.
It's something that all her members of her card...
Carry with them.
Oh my god, please!
It was just a collab!
I swear!
We're just...
I got paid...
To work with them!
I swear!
Increase your defense by 200% for a limited time.
Golden Foxy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm gonna need you to take a seat over there.
Yuan Hua.
Hello.
I'm right beside you, just tell me!
You can literally just tell me!
Okay, I have the Scorch Gems.
Boost damage to...
Okay, but I always do parry, so like...
I don't have to worry about it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I want...
Please give me back the general route.
Please, get me out of the princess route!
Get me out of the princess route!
I don't want to be here anymore!
I don't think he wants to talk.
Alright, let's see.
Who's he?
Who are you?
Is that Gan Ning?
Can I help you?
You've been looking for me?
Me?
Oh, it's Gan Ning!
Wait, where's his mohawk?
Damn, those tattoos go fucking hard.
Okay, not gonna lie...
Okay, Gan Ning...
His older design...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I actually like his older design a lot more.
He had like...
Okay, his older design was actually fucking crazy.
Like...
Gan Ning's older design was like...
He was like, yeah, I'm a bad boy.
So...
It was more like...
He was way cooler.
He was so much cooler.
Okay, let me show you guys his older design.
It's so weird, it's so weird seeing him like...
Not be a bad boy anymore.
I don't know!
I mean like, I guess he has tattoos.
But like, he was...
Yeah, he was like...
Okay, here's his older design.
I'll show you guys.
Alright, this was...
This one, to me, was his peak.
I think this one was his best design.
So, overall.
I honestly think...
And then his voice was like super gravelly.
His voice was like incredibly gravelly.
And like...
Like...
Horse and stuff like that.
And he would have like...
Yeah, that one was peak.
Then they like redesigned him to look like this.
And I was like, oh, that's alright.
Like, he still looks cool.
But like, this design...
This was peak Gan Ning.
I think.
I think this one was my favorite.
I think...
I think this one was peak Gan Ning design.
When they had their...
Yeah.
And he was like...
His like...
His voice was like super gravelly, too.
Yeah, that one was good.
Alright, now he's like...
Now he's like, I could be bad.
He's like semi-bad.
He's like...
He's like boy -bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's like...
PG-bad.
Flock together?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he is so boy-bad.
It's like sterilized...
Bad boy.
They're like...
We gotta be on...
We gotta be on Cartoon Network, guys.
Yes.
He's got one singular bell.
Why does he have one singular bell?
Oh my god!
Oh yeah.
He has one singular bell.
Alright.
Looks like you're taking a liking to my hideout.
What?
Wait, what?
Did he took me to the hideout?
And then fade to black?
What do we do?
What did we do?
Why did I take a liking?
Oh no.
No, not the off-screen.
Come see me again once you train up some more.
Oh my god, what did I do?
I know what... I know!
What do you think of this?
Okay.
You giving it all makes me feel like I can do likewise.
There is a favor I wish to ask of you.
Will you help us maintain order in Changsha?
I'll pay you for your troubles, of course.
Wait, this?
Offers you can get rewards for completing...
Oh, okay.
I mean, it's just right there.
No, we have yet to...
I don't...
It takes so long to pursue one Lu Bu.
I'm surprised we haven't pursued him yet.
I'm just as surprised as you guys.
Instead, I have to babysit a child who has a fucking crush on me.
Okay, get him out of here.
Get this bandit.
Nice.
Get out of here.
Give me that base.
Is there another officer here?
No, I killed all the officers.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice, my base now.
Alright, I'll get this other base.
This other base would be fast.
Alright, go, go horse, go!
They say you're the strongest horse out there.
Come on, get up, get up!
Cheer on, I'm cheering you on!
You got this!
Nice.
That parry was so good.
That was like an instant parry.
I literally got off my horse and I parried instantly.
Nice.
Get out!
Okay, now I just need to beat up the little guys.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right!
Your leader's dead!
I killed him and I ate him!
Because we have a famine right now.
Back in ye olde dynasty times.
I don't know if you guys know that, but like back in the Three Kingdoms era, there was a lot of famine.
There was a lot of famine back then.
We gotta eat what we can get.
Yeah, what do you think the meat and the meat buns were?
Yeah, there was a lot of...
A lot of cannibalism, surprisingly.
Surprisingly, a lot of cannibalism.
Yay!
Here, take this as a token of my gratitude.
I hope that I may call upon you again.
Get a strength potion.
Oh, I have to go backwards.
Oh, I have a letter?
You sent me a letter?
You sent me a letter.
Hello, my doctor that does nothing.
Yellow turban, remnant, heading on.
It was after you, a traveling warrior, had beat me down that it dawned to me what in the world was I doing?
I had a family, a home that I needed to protect.
And yet, I'd thrown it all away in these chaotic times.
You and I were alike.
While possessions are renowned, I had become abandoned, and you went on to save others and earn their gratitude.
I suddenly felt ashamed.
I felt a longing for home.
Please, take this so I can use my hands to hug my family when I see them again.
If they forgive me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, yellow turban, remnant.
It's great to have a fan.
Finally!
A Dragoon fan I didn't accidentally kill in war.
Alright.
Alright, let's go this way.
Time to go across the ocean.
The slowest boat ride.
Okay, nevermind.
I'll just accelerate.
I was gonna be like, this is such a fucking slow boat ride.
Yeah!
Hey, Chen Pu.
What are you doing here?
Oh no.
It's me!
I know of you.
Because I serve as an advisor to Lord Sun Jian.
I see that you are using your time between battles not to rest but to sharpen your skills.
Lord Sun Jian, Huang Gai, and even the princess have gotten quite worked up.
Oh no, no, no.
Remove that part.
The last part.
There's clearly a reason for that.
Okay, but what did they say?
They all possess a strange fondness Oh!
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
Why does it keep getting worse?!
No, it's okay.
I know which faction I'm not joining.
It would be an honor.
I need time to prepare.
Wait, is he actually inviting me to his faction?
Oh, fuck!
Fuck, okay!
Oh no, oh no!
Oh, it's just a side quest?
Okay, thank god.
Oh, thank god.
It's just a side quest.
Okay, I was gonna say I'm not...
I need to get far away from the Sun Clan.
For now.
Challenge me?
Seems I have no choice.
Okay, thank you for the super chat!
Your very first super chat!
Thank you!
Tomorrow's my birthday, so I thought I might spread some love.
Oh my god, thank you!
Thank you for super chatting on your birthday to me!
I really appreciate it!
I'll give you a birthday song now because I don't think I'm streaming tomorrow.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear MLK!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Oh, am I gonna beat up an old man?
Alright, old man.
I'm gonna teach you a lesson.
Oh, okay.
I guess not.
Alright.
Alright, goodbye.
Okay.
Alright.
We fight.
Oh yes!
We are unlocking the...
There we go.
That's fucking right.
That's it?
Oh man.
That's a little embarrassing for you.
That is so embarrassing for you right there.
Like, really?
You got parried twice, buddy!
You got parried twice!
Bro, you're already tired?
What the fuck is your stamina?
How are you... Oh my god, he can parry too?
What's he gonna say?
That's crazy.
How is my...
Your spirit has roused.
How is there moral for this one?
It's just you and me.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
Guys, you haven't even got one hit on me, bro.
Like, no wonder you're just an advisor.
Like, stay in your lane, Chenpoo.
Stay in your fucking lane.
This is embarrassing, even for...
This is so embarrassing.
Literally no damage run.
Get out of my elo.
Go back into your...
Go back into your locker, nerd.
He's not in his prime anymore, Doki.
Nice, I got parried too.
From you need to generic general.
Yeah, go back to generic general.
Who gave you a design, Chenpoo?
You used to be a nobody.
Maybe you should stay a nobody.
Alright.
Hmm.
You show skill, and not one silver hesitation or mercy.
No less fearsome than Honggai or Hongdang.
Oh, woah, woah, woah!
I look forward to the day you choose to fight under Lord Sun Jian's banner.
And feel free to come and train anytime.
I'll be happy to spar you.
You're not even a fucking challenge, buddy.
What do you mean you'd be happy to spar me?
I'm still not the right level for this guy.
Okay, wait, what's this?
Is this weapons?
Okay, any new weapons, though?
Nah, just bad weapons.
Oh wait, there's items here, though.
He meant be a looting punching bag.
I mean, basically, yeah.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, board.
Okay, nice.
I need that.
Jesus, so faroh, I should've just fast-traveled.
Hey, this is open now.
Wait, no, this was open always.
I got I completed all your requests, John Fae.
Wait, is this a date?
Would you like to join?
Oh my god!
John Fae, you're out!
Okay.
Would you like to join me?
A lunch date with John Fae?
I'm not just no one, though.
My brothers seem to like you.
And even I.
Woah, woah!
You know what?
You know You can say like me as a brother, right?
Go on.
Go on, John.
Oh my god, he's a sinner.
Oh, what?
Damn!
Woah!
Oh my god, you're right, I get three big brothers!
And no princess.
You have You're trying to win me over!
What are these choices?
Why do you keep doing this?
Why do you keep doing bros before hos?
Like I said, bros before hos.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is why it's called romance of the three kings.
Oh!
Oh my god, confirmation!
You have a problem with it?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm in!
I'm in!
Oh my god, I'm gonna get the exclusive wallpaper for unlocking Israel!
I'm gonna get the visual!
I'm gonna unlock the visual!
Oh my god, we need a fourth brother!
Brothers?
I told you, they wrote me out of history.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm gonna unlock the visual image for completing the route.
I'm gonna do it.
Oh my god.
I knew it.
I knew they rewrote.
They wrote me out of history.
I knew I was always meant to be the fourth brother.
So what happened after the train?
Who are you?
Another route?
Yes?
Water Mirror?
Hermit?
I've always wanted a brother.
Okay.
What?
I have no memories.
I hit my head and then here I am.
Not every big, goofy man wants to fade to black with me.
More than meets the eye.
share local rumors and possibly even introduce you to other visitors.
Other visitors?
Other realms?
Did you also got the incense from my child doctor?
Wow.
Alright, now that I'm here, I go out.
Like, what does he do?
Oh, where you can see information about your relationships?
What does that mean?
I'm gonna start receiving date gifts?
Okay.
Hi, I know of you.
Welcome to my dwelling.
I believe this is your name?
A warrior of superb judgment and bold actions.
Countless soldiers owe their lives to his sharp eye and gallantry.
I've heard tales of your exploits.
Many a valiant warrior is taking notice of you.
The bond you forge with him may prove to be waymarks guiding your path.
Your visit to this place will also be of help, as I have to teach you the bonds between yourself and the heroes of this land.
Alright, alright.
Now, let's see if I can introduce someone you can befriend.
Let me befriend Dong Zhuo.
Alright.
Okay.
Where are my bonds?
Oh, my level three.
My level three bond.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright, I also have a level three with John Fei.
I'm just in an acquaintance with Chen.
Oh, he's dead anyway.
Okay, at least he's dead.
Okay.
Alright.
Not so bad.
I like how they make it a handshake, but it's like...
We all know it's sort of shaped like a heart.
It's a handshake, but yet somehow, it looks so much like a heart.
These coins are no longer used as money, but they remain a token of good fortune.
Gift it to those close to you.
Receiving a coin from someone is a sign that the giver enjoys your company.
There are also coins that remain hidden in various places across the land.
Yet, they are somehow rediscovered.
No, it was a handshake.
Artifacts from ancient times once again in the hands of man after so many years.
Such a delay.
Hmm, that gives me an idea.
Bring me any old coins you collect.
I'll then give you something worthwhile in return based on how many you've brought.
Old coins given to you are a testament of your bonds with others, and any coin you find yourself are proof of your travels.
In other words, they signify the paths you've taken, and I, Chua Jin, shall reward your accomplishments.
Alright.
What do I- Can I get?
Okay, reward.
Oh my god, that's a lot of rewards.
Nice!
Ah, so your team- 10 coins!
Take this then.
Pretty sure I have more, right?
Nice, I got rocks.
Okay.
So...
Alright, so I can talk to Don Dua again.
Um...
Alright.
Let me talk.
Where is he?
He's in the...
It starts with an S, right?
Where is he?
Where's Don Dua?
What province was he in again, guys?
Uh...
Romance?
That's odd.
Is he- He was here, right?
He was in Liang province.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, there he is.
Hey, hey.
Well now, to think you go all the way to come and see me.
So you got guts to match your skills.
Rejoice, for you are about to taste the sheer winds of Liang.
I'll receive their quest.
What do I do?
Is it this?
Or is it this?
Oh, it's this!
Quelling, okay.
Alright, he's about to give me the dong.
I should not have said it like that.
Alright, get out of here.
Get out of here.
I realized what I said the moment it left my mouth.
I...
I realized my mistakes.
Why are you running?
Oh, and then you ran back?
What am I doing?
Let me meditate in front of you real quick.
Jesus Christ, this guy is very annoying though.
Oh my god.
It's so hard because there's so many horses!
Okay, goodbye.
It's fine.
Alright.
Get out of here.
He like ran back just to get his horses.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Okay.
We should be able to get inside now, right?
Let me in, let me in, let me in.
Let me in.
Do I not have enough allies?
Are they dead?
No, they're just horses.
Alright, don't worry.
Horse me time.
No more famine.
Okay, now we should be able to open this door.
Let me in.
Get over here.
That's right.
Use that baton ram.
That's right!
Again!
And again!
There we go.
Alright, I'm coming for you.
I'm fucking coming for you.
That's fucking right.
Oh wait, I didn't...
God damn it, I didn't parry that.
My entire strat relies on parry!
Okay.
Easy.
Alright, time to talk to the don.
Alright.
Plus three skill point, nice!
What am I like, missing?
Okay, I should raise my...
Okay, not her.
I should raise my relationship with the others, though.
Have fun.
Oh!
Nice!
Chestnut.
Okay, more old coins.
Alright.
Hello, don.
How very fascinating.
May the wind of Leon carry you forth to great renown.
I expect to see more of what you can do on the battlefield.
Oh nice!
He gave me a present.
What is it?
My bond with Donja has grown stronger.
That's great to hear.
Alright, let's see.
Old coins.
Can I have... Oh nice!
I have money!
Yippee!
Uh, is there any more?
Okay, there's no more bonds.
Uh...
Hello, child.
My child doctor.
And then hello, innkeeper.
Okay...
You like...
You know...
Get rid of the... Oh my god, I look so fucking dead inside.
Oh my god!
I actually look so dead inside right now.
Oh, I need sleep.
I...
What is a Consort Clan?
Yeah.
Okay.
Commoners?!
I can't believe it.
She should have been a concubine!
Guys, I'm here to gossip with my innkeeper.
And my child doctor.
While I'm getting...
Very, very drugged up right now.
Yeah,
I'm just spilling tea with my...
With my innkeeper and doctor.
Alright.
I am gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back!
Alright, letter time!
Thank you!
Alright, time to read this letter.
I'm sure he'll be a great service to you.
He was always cheerful when speaking about you.
Talking about how your desk is always so messy.
And how you put others before yourself to a fault.
I'm all but certain that the doctor and you will get along so well.
I pray that the two of you will remain safe on your journey.
Thank you for the super chat, patient!
Thank you, thank you!
I hope you don't die now that I took away your doctor.
Alright.
Recently, remnants of the Yellow Turbans calling themselves the White Way Bandits have been using their vast numbers to wreak havoc throughout the land.
All who will fight to bring peace to our world must gather in Silijo.
Silijo, sorry.
Silijo.
Join the government forces led by General Heejin to crush those savage ruffians once and for all.
Let it be known that the might of the Emperor is the light of the people.
Alright.
Suggest subjugation of the White Way Bandits.
Okay.
Alright.
It's time to destroy the White Way Bandits.
Oh my god, that's a lot of gems.
Let me get rid of them.
Let me boost that.
When making gems, you may achieve satisfying results which grant you a greater than usual yield of gems from a single pyroxen.
Oh shit, nice.
God, I have like such a strong vortex gem, but like it's no use to me.
I rarely ever send them in the air.
Alright guys, my voice is actually slowly dying.
Which is crazy because I feel like I haven't been using my voice so much.
So I might have to start at the three hour mark.
I don't want to, but like my voice is not it right now.
I don't know why it's slowly dying.
Oh wait, there's an item here.
Maybe it's all the calling.
I think it could be the calling.
I've always been like...
Alright.
Oh!
Who are you?
We'll now begin the war council.
Okay.
Will we defeat the leader?
Oh, they're just right here.
What if I just run straight at them?
Just personally.
Do not allow any of these bandits...
Oh wait, no.
I need more XP though.
Now, we have received word that thieves are raiding nearby villages.
The peasants have come begging for our aid.
Our top priority is serving the government.
And serving the government is the elimination of the bandits themselves.
Do not let your emotions sway you from that mission.
It must also be said that high-ranking members of the prestige...
The Yuan family are joining!
Oh my god, Yuan Shao has shown especially impressive spirit.
Oh my god, I heard he's really rich, guys.
I heard he owns a Ferrari.
He must just make short work of these bandits all by himself.
I've also heard Yuan Shao of the same house is already approaching with an army to attack the enemy from behind.
Zili is not far from the Emperor's home in Luoyang.
These filthy thieves cannot be allowed to run rampant here any longer.
Just one?
Yes.
I remember in the older Dynasty Warrior games, they just gave him gold armor.
Like...
They literally was like, yeah, he's that rich.
He literally is just wearing gold.
Even though it's like not...
Even though like, you know, gold is not like the most ideal armor type.
They literally just like, that's how rich he is.
Look at him, wearing gold.
Ah yes, the gold that was used for armor.
Yes, very ideal.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's get rid of him and then we'll help.
We'll help the others later.
He was asking to be straight.
Look, he needs to let the army know just how rich he is.
It's all about sending a message.
It's not about protection.
Oh my god, that should have been a parry right there.
Okay, let's get rid of him too.
Nice.
For like two days.
No, honestly for one day.
I'd be surprised if this village lasts one more day.
Get over here.
Nice.
Alright.
Come on, get over here.
Are blocking the...
We don't need reinforcements!
I am the reinforcements!
Oh my god, he's almost dead.
Wait, who's dying?
Oh shit!
Oh shit, okay, I'm coming back!
I'm coming over!
Oh no!
The noble man might die!
Who would have thought?
The guy that was not meant to...
Oh my god!
Eat your branch!
Oh thank god he ate his branch!
It's fine, he ate his branch guys.
We saved him.
We reminded him how to eat food.
It's okay guys!
We reminded him how to eat!
That's good!
I got no worries!
Oh my god.
I'm at 100.
107 now.
Oh, I have a minute.
Don't worry, I got this.
Holy shit!
Jesus!
There's so many people!
All these families I've killed!
All the widows!
Oh my god, I almost died.
I actually almost died.
I can't keep track.
There's way too many people.
There's actually way too many people.
Oh my god!
I'm just getting...
I'm just getting fucking flipped everywhere!
Oh, this is my last bread.
It was just everywhere.
Oh no.
Please, please eat your bread.
Please eat your bread.
Please.
You're literally 1 HP.
Oh, I'm so scared for you.
No!
You'd shoot!
Why didn't you eat your bread?!
I just met you!
How did he die?!
He is in gold armor.
I literally just met him!
How did he die already?!
They only have one.
Why didn't you eat your bread?!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
He refused to eat his bread.
Oh, this is so bad.
It's fine.
Oh no.
What happened?
Oh, what?
Pull it?
Why?
The pull down?
Oh, it's a new weapon!
Okay, but like...
It's worse than my other weapon though.
But like...
But it's worse.
My thing is rank 80.
Guys, I'm not used.
Sorry guys.
I already lost.
Guys, I already lost Runeshell.
Guys, I already...
We can't, guys.
We can't.
I know you want me to use the big sword.
But I literally just lost Runeshell.
And like...
Oh my god, another ambush?
Wait, what?
What do you mean ambush?
What the fuck do you mean?
Guys, I cannot risk it.
I cannot.
Okay, maybe I can.
Okay, let me check.
How?
Okay, it's 46.
I'll use it for like...
One fight.
Oh shit.
This is pretty bad.
Guys, I don't feel confident right now.
Guys...
Oh wait, he's dead.
Okay.
I feel so confident, guys.
I did it.
Okay.
We need to get a base for...
Wait, is there food here?
God fuck, I need food.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is actually so bad.
I think I can live.
I think I can live here.
Maybe.
I think it's possible.
I think I can live.
Can't be that bad, right?
Oh, I don't have allies.
Oh shit.
Okay, that's not good.
I went the wrong way.
Oh no.
Oh no, this is pretty bad.
Okay.
We'll go here so we can help them get reinforcements.
Oh my god, where are the jars?
Oh my god, where are the breakable jars?
Where the fuck are the breakable- Where are the buns?!
Are we in another famine?!
Oh, this is pretty bad.
I think we're in another famine, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm killing you as fast as I can!
Please don't die to the nerd!
Oh, okay.
Okay, it was just that easy.
Okay, nevermind.
We let one guy die.
Okay, this is your fault.
We didn't- Oh my god, this is your fault.
I came back to help you, but you didn't even need help.
You literally didn't even need help.
Okay, alright.
Alright, we lost our two generals because of you.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to be, like, super careful right now.
I'm, like, really scared.
I'm really scared right now.
Please tell me you dropped buns.
Oh, fucking course the nerd doesn't drop any buns.
Oh, fucking course he doesn't.
Oh, no.
Okay, this is gonna be a little scary, guys.
This might be a little scary, guys.
Alright, I have to activate Rage Mode.
I have to activate Rage Mode for my survival.
I gotta be very angry.
Oh my god.
Okay, that did nothing.
Okay.
Let me get back my other weapon.
That did absolutely nothing.
Okay.
Oh shit, I did not mean it.
Wait.
Oh my god, I got a bun!
Oh my god, he led me to the bun!
It's winnable!
But sword thing, dog doggy.
Sword.
Sword's so big!
I'm trying my best to assist him!
I'm fighting!
I'm literally fighting the biggest boss out there!
Oh my god, please.
Please just live.
I'm literally fighting the heart- the biggest boss in this game.
Oh my god!
Please eat a bun!
Please!
Oh, thank god!
Thank god!
I literally just needed to eat one thing and that was to be a bun.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Just keep- Just keep getting staggered.
Okay, I- I don't think I'm gonna win this.
I think this would be my first loss.
I'm not confident in my team right now.
It's literally me and the- and our main guy.
Like, I've- all my generals are dead.
It's literally me and my- Oh no!
Oh no!
All my generals are dead!
It's literally me and him!
Okay, nice.
Oh no.
Get me out of here.
If I- what?
Who is he?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh, he's bugged.
It's like, didn't I kill you?
I- I was just like, didn't I- Didn't I kill this man?
Oh.
It's fine.
You know, I could've tried- You know, okay, that's good.
We can have him there.
Okay.
That's good.
As long as he never gets activated, I can live through this.
He can live.
It's time to solo an army right now.
I can- I cannot activate it, guys.
I- literally it's me and the main general.
I can't let him die.
I can solo this.
I'll solo the entire army.
Don't worry, I got this.
It's me and him.
Okay, and like 200 arrows.
But it's me and him.
That's right.
This army has- oh my god!
A thousand?!
Oh, I- I'm a true warrior now.
Hello?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it crashed!
I have to fuck!
It's so far!
Oh my god!
My controller isn't working!
I need to reboot my game.
Legitimately, what happened was you are a true warrior and then my entire PC just killed itself.
I don't know what happened.
I- I- It's like, you are a true warrior now.
And then the game was like, what?
Are you a true warrior?
You have nothing else to accomplish anymore.
You've made it.
The game was like, you have nothing else to accomplish.
You've made it now.
I'm so sad!
No!
Oh my god!
I have to do this all over again!
I'm so sad!
Oh my god!
Alright, we're speedriding this.
We're fucking- Oh my god!
Oh my god!
I worked so hard!
I worked so hard too!
Alright, this time we can save Genshou.
We can- It wasn't a canon event, guys.
Guys, it wasn't a canon event.
We can save him.
It wasn't canon.
Okay, thank- Okay, you know what?
I think this is a good time to announce that like, um...
Haya is sending me another PC so I can do dual streaming.
At this point, I definitely needed at this point.
So I'm gonna actually have a dual PC setup.
Oh my god, I'm so sad!
Okay, nice.
Okay, this time we're gonna save Genshou.
We're gonna save him.
It's not gonna be canon, I swear.
I wonder if it's for tenacity.
I wonder if it's because I hit a thousand and that's why.
I wonder if that's why that happened.
I don't know.
Like, the timing for that is crazy though.
If that was the reason why.
Oh my god, I'm getting- Oh my god, no, not again.
Not again.
Oh no.
Oh no, I'm getting bodied everywhere.
Gotta save the rich kid this time.
Okay.
It's not as bad.
It's not as bad this time.
Nice, we did it.
Oh my god, I swear.
I wanna know.
Okay, let's try and get a thousand again and see if it actually- I'm actually curious.
Let's try to get a thousand again and see if my PC dies because of it.
I'm actually curious.
Oh, we're at 400.
We're getting there, guys.
We're getting there.
We are getting there.
Oh my god, there's so many arrows.
Oh, 500!
Halfway!
For science!
We're halfway there, guys.
Okay, Yongfei.
Isn't that the- That's the main boss.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, I canceled it.
I'm so locked in.
Jesus Christ, there's so many fucking arrows!
Get the assault in.
Okay, nice.
That's fucking- Get out of there, Yongfei!
I got the big sword that we're not gonna use, guys.
We are not using the big sword.
We are not using the big sword, guys.
The big sword, it was not that good.
Alright, for science, we're gonna figure out if it was because I became a true warrior.
We're coming over.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Sorry.
I'm coming over for real.
Don't worry!
I'm coming over to actually protect the village for real this time.
Okay, you're not stealing this kill from me.
Nice.
Alright,
nice.
Alright.
Here's the other one.
We did it.
We saved a village.
Repay me by paying for me.
This is not free service, guys.
I am a mercenary.
Oh, shit.
You guys gotta know, this isn't for free.
What?
Bro, I think you gotta worry about something else other than starving.
They're literally trying to fucking kill you.
I think you gotta worry about something else other than starving.
300 more to go, guys!
300 more!
We're almost there!
There's the head.
Me!
It's gonna be me!
Shit.
Oh, shit.
I'm trying my best.
Oh my god, they don't have names!
How are you tied to the no-namers?
Nice.
Okay.
That's it.
Oh my god, I think that guy has a name, actually.
Wait, I think that guy actually has a name.
No, he has no name!
How are you tied to a no-namer?
You have a name!
Oh my god, please.
That's right.
You know exactly what I'm doing here.
Oh, he walked into the wave.
That's funny.
How is your courage decreasing?
I'm literally winning every fucking fight out there.
Oh my god, please.
Please stop being bad!
Why are my generals so fucking bad?
Nice.
Get out.
Okay.
Can't die.
I'm working so hard right now.
I'm actually I'm actually speedrunning this so hard.
Come on.
Can't let them die.
Alright, you didn't show.
Do not die.
He has no name and you're rich.
That's all I asked for.
Okay, nice.
I wonder if I have to help him with the reinforcements, too.
Because I had to deal with this first.
Alright, open the gates.
Boom.
Alright.
It's time.
It's time to be angry.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's time to actually be angry.
I can't see anything, but I think I'm being angry right now.
Okay, nice.
I got the break just in time.
Nice.
Alright, this is going a lot faster than before.
Thank fucking God.
Nice parry.
Alright, use my musou.
Yeah, the big story was definitely not it.
Oh, 100 left.
Guys, 100 left.
We're almost there.
Oh, he just got back up.
100 left.
We're almost there.
Oh, shit.
Okay, not easy.
I'm not parrying this.
Why am I not parrying it?
There's too many guards!
Jesus Christ.
He's like breaking everything.
We're getting there.
We gotta test our hypothesis soon.
Okay.
Get this guy out of here too.
Get him out of here.
That's fucking right.
How many openings are there?
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Hahaha.
The moment of truth, guys.
The moment of truth, everybody.
Alright.
982!
997!
I am now a true warrior.
Army of one!
Here I cure my cause!
Wait, I'm still alive.
My PC is still holding strong!
This is it!
It has adapted!
I am a true warrior!
I have no more HP.
Holy crap!
Guys, this is bad.
Guys, I don't have any more buns now.
Oh no.
Not the call to assemble.
Oh no, where am I?
Where am I?
No!
Take the northwest base?
I have to take the base?!
Wait, how do I do this?
How do I?
Oh no, this is bad.
How the fuck do I take the base in two minutes?
Okay, this is bad.
This is bad.
I don't think I'm supposed to...
Oh no.
I don't think I can take that base in fucking two minutes.
Oh, there's too many people!
I have to kill him.
Oh no.
I actually need to kill him in time.
But I don't know if that's possible.
There's no way!
What base?
Wait, what base am I supposed to take?
Oh, this base?!
Oh shit.
I just realized he meant this base.
Oh fuck, okay.
Okay, I just realized which base it is.
I just...
One minute, let's go!
If I get angry, I can do it.
I can do it.
I just need to get very angry.
It's fine.
Oh thank god, I did it!
I got very angry!
We did it!
Oh my god, I'm breakdancing.
That's right!
Hear me breakdance before I use my Musou!
Alright, that's fucking right, you're not.
You're not going to win.
I forgot to grab some bread.
Oh, this is bad.
I legitimately forgot to grab some bread while I got here.
Alright, alright guys, I'll be right back.
Oh shit!
Guys, I'll be right back.
Let me grab some bread real quick.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
Let me grab some bread real quick.
Where are the bread containers?
There it is.
I'm coming back soon.
Nice!
I did it!
Successful!
Oh my god, we did it guys!
We fucking did it!
I don't know what happened, but we fucking did it!
Oh my god, good job everybody!
I don't know what happened, but good job everyone!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I've always known we could do it.
I was very hungry.
Sorry team.
I was incredibly hungry, but it's okay, I'm here now.
Oh shit.
It's okay, I'm here now.
Don't worry.
Oh my...
Holy shit!
Bro, it's like everybody's here.
Bro, you just got fucking mobbed by the entire army.
There we go, we did it.
That poor guy, he got actually mobbed.
Get him, Mike!
We did it!
Oh my god, we fucking did it!
One crash doesn't stop me!
For Doki!
It was like an actual Zerg rush, that was fucking crazy.
Look at that!
Crashing was good, guys.
We saved Renshao.
We changed the cat in the event.
We saved him.
Oh nice, we got...
Oh wait, no, we need one more.
That was crazy.
That crash was fucking crazy.
Oh nice.
Oh, I got three.
Unlocked three.
One battle art chain.
What the fuck is a battle art chain, though?
Attack, attack...
And then, we'll go there.
The timeline has been changed.
I saved the rich kid.
Guys, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
PC-san is a true warrior, too, now.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
We can't just go against the Grand General's orders, can we?
Yeah, I know that, but still...
Su Li is right on the Emperor's doorstep, and yet the whole place is gone to hell.
Take a look around town first.
Carefully return... Yeah, I won't take a look around.
See what they say.
Oh, I know what they're saying.
Oh, cat!
Hello, cat.
What are you doing here?
Who's she?
Father?
These bandits?
They're wearing a soldier gear.
Yao Chen?
They're purple.
Where'd she go?
Magic?
Burn the witch!
Witch!
Oh, shit!
Where's her drumsticks?
Oh,
shit!
That's me!
Fuck!
Oh, you're right.
It was a whip again.
Okay, Yao Chen's fucking weapons keep changing every time.
I only remember her the most with the drumsticks.
Because it was so silly.
And now she has...
I don't know...
A fucking nail?
One nail!
That is not efficient at all.
Where are you?
One needle.
What are we gonna do?
We can't keep going back to the bodies to get that needle.
How do you know that name?
Yao Chen?
Oh, you just guessed that, right?
Oh, whoops!
Sorry, I skipped your turn.
I could say the same to you.
How old is she?
Before I say this, guys, I need...
No, she marries Lu Bu and Dong...
The Dong, so she should be fine.
I may not look it, but I served as the governor of Yu Province during the Yellow Turban Rebellion.
But amidst the chaos, the attendants with connections to the Yellow Turbans managed to soil my name enough for me to be deposed.
The attendants are mere servants, yet their influence was enough to rob me of my position in such a humiliating way.
Shame is unbearable.
I've been traveling the land ever since, searching for a way to put a stop to the attendants' corruption and for men of character to help me do so.
A way to end corruption?
During the Three Kingdom Era?
Good fucking luck!
My father has lost his position as governor.
Together, we are but a man and his daughter with little power between us.
That's why we need someone we can rely on.
At this very moment, the attendants are fleeing to their despotic grasp.
Nothing is done to stop them.
The world will once again fall into chaos.
Zzluan, I must ask you for one thing.
If you have not yet chosen a lord to serve, could you travel with me as my guest for a time?
For money, yeah?
Sure.
Tao Chan can protect you.
You know what?
She's a strong, independent woman.
The attackers from before aren't the only ones after our heads.
The attendants have sent assassins as well.
I don't believe that they can defeat Tao Chan.
But the burden is too much for her to bear alone.
I'll do it.
I refuse.
Wait, wait, wait.
we will likely be ruthlessly killed after a bitter struggle in the middle of nowhere.
Okay, cool.
But we definitely won't hold it against you.
Please, don't trouble yourself with worries of our safety.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Manipulation.
What is this guilt trip?
Thank you.
I knew you'd have a change of heart.
Bro, what do you mean?
I wasn't even given a choice.
I can't even say no.
It was one choice.
I literally only have one choice.
Why even give me that choice?
It might as well just be a continuous dialogue.
The fact that they even made me choose the one choice is crazy.
I just took a message for you from someone who said they were with Wang Yun.
Wang Yun?
They said Wang Yun is waiting to receive word from a collaborator.
So he wants you to stay here in town for the time being.
Also, he has some business to attend to in town, so you should feel free to go and ask him if anything is unclear.
I'm not sure what this is all about, but please try not to put yourself in too much danger.
I can't cure you if you're dead.
Have you even done anything for me?
He literally has done nothing since becoming my doctor.
Hello, Diao Chan.
That's me.
I am so grateful that you have agreed to help my brother.
Oh yeah.
Out of free will.
Our fates are now bound together.
If you have any worries or misgivings about what lies ahead, let's talk them over now.
What about you and Wang Yun?
He took me in as his daughter, but I am also his student and a loyal servant.
My father is trying to root out the corruption that the attendants have inflicted on the world.
I hate to break it to you.
It's 2025 and he's still here.
There's still corruption.
Your dad failed.
Oh my gosh, she's giving me her life story?
I was born in a small mountain village.
It was decided that I would become a spy.
So I underwent training.
But one day, a large fire broke out in the village.
That was when I met Wang Yun.
I had nowhere to go.
But he took my hand and led the way.
He trained me to be the weapon that would rid the world of corruption.
Oh, it didn't work.
Should a spy really be sharing that?
Look, she said she was training to be a spy.
It didn't mean she was successful.
Her village burned down before it was too late.
It didn't mean she passed.
Oh, what?
Wait, really?
Oh yeah, he didn't have a child.
She never said she was a good spy.
Spy.
I am spy.
Oh my god, we're getting close to just the kingdoms now.
And your collaborators.
Yeah,
but isn't the empress' family also super corrupted?
I mean, they're all bad.
I don't fucking know.
They're all bad.
As long as they pay me, I'm fine.
As long as I get paid, oh, who cares?
They are all probably bad.
We need war so I can get paid.
Okay, let's see here.
Okay, I want to be sure that...
Alright, let's check the...
What was it?
I want to look at...
My... Oh, there you go.
Okay, I just finished...
Finished a lot of them.
Did I finish everything for one of some of them?
I don't remember.
Oh well.
You know what?
I should go check on...
Where's my fast travel?
I should check the friendship meter.
Just in case.
I want to make sure I have no...
I don't have anybody I need to talk to.
Okay, no.
Nobody wants to talk to me.
Okay, that's...
That's cool.
No one wants to talk to me.
That's okay.
Alright, let's go here.
Let's fast travel here.
Oh, wait!
What's this?
Oh, I'm...
Level 16?!
I am so under level.
Holy fuck.
Oh, wait.
I missed a new letter?
What are you thinking?
Is that what you call yourself now?
For one of such skill to lose their memories and end up a dog to Wang Yun?
The irony knows no bound.
I wonder...
Was it the allure of that beautiful woman or the habitual servitude that's ingrained in your nature which led to this?
Oh my god, my first auntie.
And what became of the other one from your village?
If it is her absence that has enabled your stupidity.
How pitiful...
Oh my god, my first auntie!
Ye olde dragoon auntie!
Papa Smurf, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
My mom came to visit and I had your meow meow video on.
Aww, that's so cute!
Thank you for the superchat, Papa Smurf.
Thank you, thank you.
I made it, guys!
I made it into three kingdoms!
How pitiful that would be.
And in case you had best not forget that you only live because of all those who perish.
Or rather, it would be more apt to say that you had best remember.
Hey, at least he gave me a superchat.
At least...
Guys, he gave me a superchat though!
You know?
Oh my god, that was nice.
He sent a superchat just to hate.
Just to auntie me.
He's a hate watcher.
Alright, I'll make sure he doesn't die.
Wait, who gave Dao Chan a sword?
Who gave you a fucking sword?
What happened to your needle?
Oh shit.
Alright, let's get rid of him.
Alright.
Get rid of him.
Nice.
Do a flip.
Alright.
He's just gonna get up and run away.
Wait, where do I go?
Do they just follow me?
Oh, they do.
They just follow me.
Okay.
I choose right side.
Let's buy.
Damn.
They're just doing it for the money, guys.
It's not black and white.
They're broke.
Okay.
Let's get rid of him too.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Where's the last guy?
Oh no, don't touch him.
He's old.
Okay, nice.
I wonder if I can like trigger all the ambushes by myself.
Or do they have to go through?
Okay, yeah.
I have to...
Yeah, I can trigger it myself.
Look, I'm scouting.
I'm just scouting, old man.
Not my fault you don't have a horse.
How is that my fault?
I'm sorry, man.
You're the stupid chat thing.
No, you're not.
Oh, look at him.
Oh man, if only you had a horse.
Oh man, if only.
It's too bad you don't have a horse.
It's too bad.
Alright, let's get him out of here.
That's fucking right.
God damn it, I fucked up the parry.
My parry timing has been off lately.
Wait, there's another assassin?
Oh my god, you go for the other assassin.
You go for the other assassin.
I have to deal with this.
Oh my god, he was just beat.
Diao Chan, save your dad.
Diao Chan, your fucking dad is getting beat up.
Jesus Christ, these assassins are so tanky though.
Oh my god.
Jesus, you're so tanky.
Please, he must rest.
Nice.
Okay, we got him out.
Your turn now.
Get out of here.
God damn it, I'm missing my parry.
It's not good.
That's right.
There you go, parry!
My first parry of the day!
There you go.
That's right, you thought you could just dash?
Jesus.
Alright.
Are you still resting?
Mom, where's your horse?
Man, if only somebody would give their horse for you.
Poor old man.
Poor guy.
Which way are we going?
Oh, this way?
Oh.
Wait, what the fuck?
How do I get over there?
Oh, he just drops down!
Oh, whoops!
I was like, how do I get out of there?
And I just run away from them.
Okay.
Yeah.
Trust me.
I didn't just try to run away from you guys earlier because I fucked up.
I totally know what I'm doing.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, I think I should've leveled up more.
My fucking weapons are so bad right now.
Oh my...
I'm so weak!
Everybody takes so long to kill!
Yeah.
Another one?!
Oh my god, Diaochan, please.
Diaochan, you're not even injured.
Even if it cost me my life.
Full HP.
Got him.
Alright, nice.
Alright, just run.
Ignore him.
Oh my god, there was an assassin.
Nevermind, you can't ignore him.
Sorry.
I didn't realize.
Sorry, I didn't realize there was nearly an assassin right in front of you.
I was gonna be like, ignore the arrows, just run forward.
The arrows can't do anything.
Okay, nice.
Alright, just keep going.
There should be...
There has to be another ambush.
I don't believe we're safe.
Oh my god, he's so slow.
I don't understand why he didn't bring his own horse.
Like, why are you running like a commoner?
You're literally a noble.
Like, what happened to you?
You fell off, old man.
You fucking fell off, bro.
We're literally right there.
Why, diaochan?
We're right there.
You should have made him go.
We're literally right there.
The exit is literally right there.
But even the random soldier said you're wrong, diaochan.
Oh my god.
Alright, c'mon.
C'mon.
C'mon, old man.
C'mon, run.
Run.
That's why you got this.
You can do this.
C'mon, you can do this.
I believe in you.
Look at you go.
Okay, so resting...
Oh, it was an ambush.
Oh.
It was an ambush this entire time.
I can't believe it.
They just lied like that?
In the battlefield?
That's so fucked.
Oh yeah, they already took over.
That's right.
It's not difficult when I'm angry.
Oh no.
Wait.
Oh no, not the dog.
Oh no.
He saw the pretty lady.
Wait, Chao Chao?
I'm breakdancing real quick.
Wait, what is Chao Chao doing here?
Chao Chao!
I did it.
Wait, what the fuck is Chao Chao doing here?
Oh shit!
Oh!
Whoa!
We're in a battlefield right now.
Chao Chao, calm down.
I'm trying to kill somebody.
It must be destiny that we're here.
What am I doing?
Oh, whoops.
I fucked it up.
Nice.
Alright, last guy.
Don't worry, Chao Chao.
Watch this.
It's pretty hot.
Oh, is that hot?
Yeah?
Is this what you mean by destiny?
Oh shit!
Sorry.
Get him in here.
Kill him real quick.
Whoops.
Whoa!
Nice, I dodged it.
Don't worry, he didn't see that, guys.
He didn't see that.
We're fine.
Ta-da!
That's right.
Just us two.
Nobody else.
Oh nice, my wheels are stronger.
Uh, L, Y while evading.
Oh, I can actually use my evade.
Okay, plus 15 skill point.
Oh, I did it!
I did the battle art chain!
Okay, uh...
I wanna upgrade my yellows first before I go on to the next one.
Lord Wang Yun, I am glad to see you in good health.
I am here to welcome you on orders from the Grand General.
I am very grateful.
We expected assassins, but the bandits were a surprise indeed.
I must also give my thanks to Lord Dong Zhuo.
The dog!
Thank you.
God, why are you naked?
Sorry, his face is naked.
I didn't mean it in any way.
He's so naked without a mustache.
So weird.
We're here at West Dash.
We should celebrate Lu Bei.
We're evil.
I would not disgrace such a fine gathering by showing up as filthy as we are.
Is that so?
We've set up camp outside the capital.
We'll rest our feet there.
Damn, I like how they put like evil music on him while he talks.
Like he's not even saying anything evil.
He's just like, I'll set up camp!
And they're like, evil music play.
He's so evil for setting up camp.
An evil camp.
The power of a beast.
You should rest for tonight, Lord Wang Yun.
We will discuss the future with Grand General He Jin later.
It's been too long, Luan.
I knew we would meet again one day.
But I never expected to see you as a retainer of Lord Wang Yun.
I am happy that a man of such rank has taken an interest in you.
But I find it slightly unfortunate as well.
What?
Unfortunate?
Indeed.
We all feel the same way.
Lord Wang Yun- Woah!
I am such a hot commodity!
Things would have been a lot easier.
That's for sure.
Woah, so many offers!
Our allies in this fight are most notably Lord He Jin and Lord Wang Yun.
The Yellow Turbans are not long gone and now corruption has taken root at the seat of power.
We must sever those roots or prepare to face the next Zhang Jiao.
I don't know how much you already know, but the situation in Luoyang is going to get rough.
Alright, I'm gonna go to the highest bidder.
You're going to the capital too, right?
If we both make it out alive, I hope we meet again.
Oh my god, oh there's so many choices guys!
So many choices!
Which one do I go to?
I could be the fourth brother.
I could be Xiao Xiao's other short king.
We don't talk about the Sun family.
So many choices!
We could go with the Deng.
I can be the Deng's Deng?
Woah!
Let's talk about the Emperor.
Yeah, but then there's the other one.
The Empress's family.
If I don't go to Tao, you only get one clap!
I'm so hyped!
I like how that's supposed to be my motivation to pick Tao Tao.
They're like, don't you want to look at Xiao Hu Dan's one eye patch though?
His sexy one eye!
Guys, I'm gonna tell you guys now, I'm picking Xu so I can see how hot Zhuge Liang is.
And then I wanna see Pangtong die for the 8th time.
Or not even 8th, for the 13th time.
Be careful out there.
Good night and sweet dreams.
That's like literally my only motivation.
I'm here to see how hot Kongming is.
And, um, oh this is a fancier inn.
And, um, Pangtong's death yet again.
I think the worst part is that- Sorry, spoiler alert!
They always bait you that you could potentially save him, but he is never the worst.
Like, it's a canon event.
So like, even if you do everything you can to save him, he will always die.
Like, they'll just be like, they just give you a cutscene.
Like, I had one moment where I actually save- saved him, and then like, killed the people that were trying to kill him.
And then I killed him, and then they just cutscene kill him off.
And I was like, what the fuck?
I was just like, oh my god, this is it.
I'm gonna change canon!
And then they literally- he just fucking gets a heart attack and dies.
And I was like, what the- what's the point?
Rebellion of the Ten Attendants.
Oh, is this where- oh shit, I'm at the- I'm at the imperial court already.
Oh my god, they took me here?
Oh, hey there.
Defeat 50 foes while in rage mode.
Defeat while using a portal.
Defeat 50 foes while using- oh.
Oh shit, this is my route.
This is- there's my route right there.
Oh, I didn't unlock this?
Sili Province.
I love that name.
It's so silly.
I don't know why it's such a- It's such a good name, Sili Province.
What is new?
Oh, the weak swords are new.
Um...
Oh, what?
Jump up while spinning, thrusting forward.
Use the wheels and you're holding a sweet to sweep at.
Oh wait, I'll buy this.
It's full of whimsical silly.
I wanna get rid of this, I feel like.
Yeah, we'll try that.
Wait, that's so cool.
I don't know why I wanna...
Huh.
Crawling dragon seems- Okay.
Uh...
The tornado- Use the wheels you're holding to sweep at anything around you.
Able to stop certain attacks and stagger the enemy.
Okay, we're gonna do that.
There's so many choices though, so it's hard to pick.
Restore health by 5% when- Okay, we're gonna do that.
We always like kill people anyway.
Actually, uh...
There was one...
Damage boost.
Where's the one where like- Yeah, we'll try this one.
Uh...
Okay, where are my objectives?
Let's try and get some objectives done actually.
Uh...
Oh, let's do- Okay, full with spear.
Okay.
We're gonna- Let me get out my spear and raise my relationship with Guan Yun.
Let me- Let me- Wait, I think I can buy- I can buy the strong spear.
Uh...
I should have the spear.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Don't say it like that!
Okay.
I got it.
I'm sorry.
Guys, I have to unlock more of the route!
I need to unlock the Guan Yun route!
Alright, rich man.
Okay.
He's gonna steal your mustache, Yuan Shao.
Hmm...
Where is the Grand General?
We are here to meet him, but he is nowhere to be seen.
Gentlemen, please excuse the interruption.
I have a message for you from my father, Wang Yun.
Lord He Jin has been summoned to the palace by Imperial decree.
Please, make haste to the Imperial court.
What?
To the Imperial court?
We are to dive into that snake's den with those attendants?
It may well be a trap, but one cannot refuse a decree.
Come on!
What's so wrong about that?
You have me!
I'm literally like the secret fourth brother!
Oh, alright.
He's being held captive by the attendants of the palace!
Oh, you're such an idiot, He Jin.
Already?
You literally just got the message and you're already captured?
That was not even like 10 seconds!
But the die has already been cast.
There is no turning back now.
How did he get captured in 10 seconds?
Bring the attendants to justice in Lord He Jin's name.
Yeah, Chen literally came over and was like, alright, he's over there, he's heading there, and then the other guy was just like, by the way, he's fucking...
Alright, bye.
Oh, nice!
Oh my god, the cool... Oh, no, no, we're not going alone.
I'm fucking crazy for trying to go alone without...
the Shahooden?
Oh my god, guys, I'm in front of a celebrity right now.
Alright, let's begin battle.
Oh my god, this man is an actual celebrity.
He's so cool.
Oh?
Oh, I can bring a horse inside the fortress.
Okay.
Okay, I need to use my...
Oh, not that.
Okay.
Alright, I was like, what am I doing?
Oh, shit.
I need to use more of my battle.
Oh my god, fuck!
Okay, nice.
Hey.
There you go.
Goodbye.
This is for Guanyun!
Oh, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh,
I hated this.
Oh, they're doing this map?
This was like so confusing for little me.
Oh, no.
Not the hidden passage.
Where is it?
How do I find...
Is it this?
Boom, boom, boom.
How do you...
Oh.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking stupid.
I forgot the power of freedom.
With the power of freedom!
I did it.
I used the power of freedom.
That's fucking right.
I'm getting over it.
That's right.
You're gonna die by my hands for Guanyun's relationship route.
I'm doing it for one thing and one thing only.
Jesus Christ, I could have just opened the door.
Is that it?
But the coolness factor, the Doki don't understand.
It wouldn't look as cool.
Alright, open up.
I can't use my hands for that.
That's for common.
I was like...
I was like... Alright, open up.
Alright, guys.
Do it for me.
Can't dirty these hands.
Alright, let's go.
For my relationship route!
I need to use my battle arts too.
That was easy.
Is that it?
Wait, they're all dead.
That was so easy.
They're already all dead!
Where do I go?
Oh, this way.
Wait, who do I follow?
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
I know what I'm doing.
Oh, shit!
You saw that?
That was a sick move right there.
Wait, he got murdered already?
Okay.
I'll kill him though.
Wait, when did he die?
This fight hasn't even been 5 minutes and he's already dead?
Oh my god, no.
Not another magician.
Let's go.
Oh, Chow Chow will be okay.
He'll be fine.
He'll be so fine.
We don't need to help him, right?
Okay, one of the ten...
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Wait, he got stronger!
Wait, how?
You're a nerd!
It's okay.
I like how Chow Chow just has to deal with magic and I'm just fighting.
He's just like... He doesn't even have any enemies with him, so he should be fine.
He's a strong nerd.
Get out of here.
Now it's not attendance.
You gotta rename yourself.
Yeah, I'm just fighting bureaucrats.
Yeah, I was like, these are just politicians.
How could they get stronger?
Oh, wait, I can't go here.
What is he fighting?
Who are you fighting?
Who is this guy?
Okay, we gotta save Chow Chow.
Oh shit, okay.
Chow Chow's the one that's actually fighting someone.
Okay, I gotta get through here.
Wait, there's actual people here?
Oh no, not a secret!
There's always secret passages!
Come on.
Oh my god, I am not parrying!
God damn it!
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, Chow Chow defeated the magician!
Okay, there is... Wait, what?
What?
How is he getting there?
Oh god, he disappeared.
Disappear!
Okay, where's the entrance to this guy?
Where's the secret door?
It's here.
Alright, peekaboo!
Knock, knock!
I know your secret.
Hello?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Okay, I...
Oh, it's such a shame that the treasure room had no treasure.
Such a shame, guys, right?
There was no treasure in here when I got here, guys.
None at all.
Oh man, what a shame when I got here, all the treasure was gone.
Oh man!
Truly is a shame.
What a travesty.
Not a single...
Oh man, the attendants, they stole them all, guys.
It's actually crazy.
When I got there, that one attendant that we were trying to find, he was just gone.
I have no idea where he went.
What?
This will help with...
Yeah!
Oh my god, the attendants were so fast.
Like...
What would I do with all that gold?
Oh my god, I keep doing the wrong fucking move.
Shit.
That's what I could find.
That's right, get up there.
Okay, we gotta get the seventh attendant?
God, I killed so many.
How are they...
Shit!
Oh fuck, okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
I have bread.
Oh, nice.
Parried?
Not really.
Now I parried.
There we go.
Come on, get out of here.
Jesus Christ, why were there ten?!
I couldn't be like, I don't know, five.
Okay, nice.
Oh shit.
Oh, Tata, I'm coming to work.
Give me a sec, let me get this one attendant.
Please, you can't die to a bureaucrat!
Wait, how do I get there?
Oh no.
Wait, this is bad.
I don't know how to get over.
Oh wait, it was this way.
Whoops.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
Oh my god, Tata, how could you just die to a bureaucrat?
He doesn't do anything!
Okay, let's see, where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
Wait, actually, where is he?
Is he here?
Wait, where are you?
Wait, did he run?
Tata?
Wait, what?
Just ran away!
Oh my god, he's right here.
There you go, get out of that sky.
Sky is for birds.
Yo, he's fine.
Yeah, he literallyyou're so fine.
You're so healthy.
He literally ran away because he was like, this isn't a challenge anymore.
Alright, nice.
Wait, I can change characters.
There we go.
I can play an actual real person now.
Oh my god!
Finally, I'm playing the real game!
I'm playing a real game now.
Let's go!
The real Dynasty Warriors.
That's fucking right.
I have two eyes!
I'm literally so strong!
Nice.
We got the other tenant.
Okay, let's...
open the door.
My commoner hands won't touch the door.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
He's so fucking cool.
Oh my god, no!
No, don't leave it to him!
It's not as cool!
No, why do we leave it to him?
But he's not as cool though.
Okay, nice.
Get out of here.
Okay, we actually need more bread.
Good guy.
Where's the other tenant?
I guess I have to open this.
Ooh.
Where are you?
Yeah?
You're not one of them?
That's what a liar would say.
Get out of here.
That's fucking right, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I don't believe in bureaucrats.
You think a politician would tell that truth?
That's fucking right.
I don't believe in poli- Yeah, why is your health bar red?
I hate it.
Oh my god, kill the defenseless man.
Oh my- The last guy to die, kill a defenseless man.
That's fucking right, I'll do it again.
Could a bureaucrat do a perfect parry?
That's right, I don't think so.
Nice.
My horse takes fucking forever to level up, though.
350 enemies.
Wait, I haven't unlocked anything for Guan Yun yet!
I thought I did so much!
Alright, back to the Dong camp.
Hmm, just as I expected.
Looks like we've caught something valuable this time.
It's time for the evil camp, guys.
The emperor is coming.
We must welcome him in the proper fashion.
Yes, sir!
Let us begin.
This will be a feast fit for royalty.
After eliminating Tenet Jiangrong and Luo Yang, Dong Zhuo placed the emperor under his own protection, and positioned his troops outside of the capital in anticipation of the opportunity created by the chaos within.
He went on to claim the right to rule for himself and march... I like how they put that in exposition.
The emperor was reduced to a little more... Oh my god!
He was evil all along?!
Who would have thought!
As the evil music played in the background!
And how he was evil for the last, I don't know, 10 plus years!
All who opposed him were executed without exception.
The Dong's followers used their strength and authority to subjugate the peasantry, greedily indulging in their basest desires.
The streets of Luo Yang echoed with cries of violence, suffering, and death.
Oh my god!
Who would have thought!
This could be it!
The number of wounded and sick grows each day.
The majority of local doctors must have already fled.
Are you going to flee as well?
Don't say such things.
If you are to remain in Luo Yang, then I will too.
What have you done for me?
Besides, I still haven't cured you yet.
But...
You were trying?!
This is my advice as a man of medicine.
Lord Wang Yun may have ordered you here, but I think we should leave Luo Yang.
To stay is to invite death itself.
Luo Yang has become a battlefield.
One wrong word could mean the end for you.
Excuse me.
Oh, hello, Diao Chan.
I wish to speak with you about my father, but I see that I am interrupting.
Ah, I see.
I have some other matters to attend to anyway.
Please, take your time.
Thank you.
She was like, he was getting too close to you.
I don't like it.
He seems to be very troubled about the recent events in Luo Yang.
Lord Dong Zhuo's men have rampaged through the city, and I hear he has been equally disruptive in the imperial court.
I am certain my father feels responsible for this.
In order to deal with the ten attendants, he unleashed an even greater threat.
He blames himself for that.
I mean, he literally left a vacuum.
Like, what?
He had no like, plan B after like, step two of this plan.
It's literally, kill the bureaucrats, and then like, we'll see what happens.
Let's find a way together, Yao Chen.
Before you get married like, three more times.
Women?
Oh my, Yao Ye.
I didn't know it at the time, but I think I came here hoping to hear those exact words.
I've been talking to a lot of women for this part of the game.
Yeah, that's what I said.
But I don't care.
I literally thrive off of this.
Like, that's my job.
As long as there's always war, I'll get paid.
Okay...
Oh...
This is where I choose the...
This is where I choose a faction.
Superchat, thank you, thank you.
I can't believe the Dong was a tyrant.
He has such a trustworthy looking design.
I know, right?
I'm gonna choose the most worthless one, because they have the hottest characters.
Guys, we all know Shu is actually pretty much worthless as a faction.
Real.
Alright, observation report.
Okay,
it's very fucking weird that you're watching me sleep.
It's possible that some of your memories are returning to you in those dreams, but it's best to avoid forcing them out.
Digging too deeply into the past while firmly establishing your present self is a dangerous endeavor.
Okay, thank you, my doctor.
Not Doki, I'm Yun Shao.
I offer you the great honor of...
Oh my god, what a fucking honor.
The head of renowned houses of Yun.
Face to face, a mere soldier like yourself may feel unworthy of my presence, but you need not...
Oh my god, I so relate with Yun Shao.
Dragoons!
I am gracing you with my presence!
No need to cry, but you need not trouble yourself with such misgivings.
I simply wish to speak with you.
Come with an unburdened heart.
No super chats today.
Unlucky.
She's so god.
Oh my god, we're not worthy.
Oh my god, him?
Does he work for Cao Cao?
Is that the same guy I'm thinking of?
That works for Cao Cao and Sima Yi?
And you are?
The hook guy, yeah.
Yeah, Jia Xu.
Aren't you busy right now?
That seems... Aren't you busy right now?
I don't know, you're pretty suspicious right now.
Yeah, he's the...
Yeah, he...
He works for a lot of bad people.
You literally have a Jafar beard.
Like, I can't trust you at all.
Like, you have the beard of evil.
Oh.
Are we gonna bond?
I like him.
How long till he backstabs you?
What is it?
I so foolish.
You never give me a choice, so I might as well say yes cause there's no other choice.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, she has so much riz.
Just walk!
There's a pathway!
Wow!
Hey guys!
Look at my choices!
She's like, wow, you're really gonna say yes without me telling you what my choice... What it is?
And I'm just like, yeah.
What other choice do I have?
Just... Sure.
I can't thank you enough.
Alright, let's get going, shall we?
Fade to black.
Oh my god!
It unfaded to black?
What is this?
Just cause she's a woman?
The very first time it unfaded to black!
From black!
Oh my god!
We actually have a date cutscene!
She laughed at my...
What I said, but I said nothing funny.
I'm so in.
Literally look at my face.
I knew I wasn't saying anything funny.
Oh my god and the smile.
Whoa!
An expression that's not dead inside?
Oh my... I'm not disassociated as fuck?
A reaction?
What's this thing?
You guessed it.
Hahaha!
You...
This can't be your first date.
You literally, like, marry three different people.
Sorry, I accidentally skipped that part.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
And then she picked Lu Bu over me.
Like...
It's not fair.
She picked Lu Bu in the end.
Okay.
I guess let me just talk to the Dong right after.
Right after...
Well, it's Lu Bu, Doki.
You, anyone, would pick Lu Bu in the end.
Okay, that might be true.
That, uh...
Hahaha!
That might be true.
Okay, uh...
Alright, let's talk to the Dong right after.
That lovely moment we had with Diao Chan.
I'd like to recognize your achievements yet again.
So, have you seen the state of the capital?
No one can deny it at this point.
The Han dynasty is rotting from the inside.
Oh yeah, talk more politics to me.
Utilize your authority.
Make a preemptive strike.
What would he like?
What would he like, guys?
Guys, if I had to successfully woo the Dong, what would he want me to say?
Utilize your authority?
Or...
You're right, he likes authority.
Will my actions lead to a world thriving on war?
Or one of chaos ruled by death?
It's difficult to say.
If something isn't done, however, the rot is sure to steadily spread.
I refuse to accept that.
What's more, I've obtained the power necessary to change that.
So, how about it?
Would you be interested in serving me?
No.
And no.
No!
My Dong route!
I don't wanna... No!
I wanna keep all options open!
Get in!
No, we can't serve no Dong for us, guys!
The Dong route has been denied!
I'll find my own path.
Woah!
Woah, I'm dying!
Submitting to no one, and making the presence of the storm known.
That wind carries with it the life I desire.
It has been a true pleasure.
Go now, move through the land under your own freedom.
The Dong route is dead, but he's not giving up.
Oh, my bond with the Dong has grown stronger!
What the fuck happened?
How did it grow stronger?
Alright.
I need to defeat foes with YYY.
Okay, I just have to do YYY.
Okay.
Who are you?
I'm playing hard to get and he likes that.
Hahaha!
Hello?
Oh, it's another like Chao Chao.
He's so generic.
Heh.
Yeah, I hope so too, guys.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I genuinely hope they make DLC with more factions to join.
Oh, they do that too.
I have the proper documentation if you'd like to see.
That was crazy.
That was such a crazy statement.
Holy fuck.
And then my fucking bond grows stronger.
Sasha passed or hasn't.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's definitely been a really good game though.
I've been enjoying it a lot.
I'm pretty sure I'm still like just in the beginning of this game.
That's crazy.
I'm still at the beginning.
Use me?
Um, I am a person and not a toy.
Alright.
Okay, that goes for the next stage.
Scissors.
Okay, Yuan Shao.
Hello.
If I'm gonna increase my bond with anyone, I'm gonna increase my bond with the rich guy.
I am not a gold digger, guys.
I'm just saying.
You gotta have friends in powerful places.
What is this?
That's me.
Bro, am I like... Bro, I feel like every fucking general has been like...
They're...
They all want me.
You heard about that?
Nexie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki is not a toy.
Go buy a Doki Brain plushie now!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sorry.
I just went, sorry.
Excuse me.
Sorry, I don't know.
I don't know.
I cannot.
Will you join?
I won't leave Wanyun.
Why can't I join the gold boys?
He's literally wearing an armor made of gold.
The most inefficient metal out there.
And he has two J's.
J doesn't even protection.
It's just fancy.
It's not even protection.
Okay, conquer bases five times.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta do a mission.
Alright, my father's enemies must be eliminated and I'll ask your help in seeing it through.
Prevention of Wanyun's assassination?
Where is he gonna get assassinated?
Alright, we're gonna make sure you don't die again.
Alright, Wanyun.
We gotta make sure you live.
Okay.
Nice, okay.
Jesus Christ, I feel so weak.
But actually, since I need to I just need to use Y all the time.
Jesus Christ, the Y takes fucking forever though.
The Y attack actually takes so long.
Alright, you know what?
Fuck this.
I'll use the- I'll complete it in the- in the fucking regular fights.
These assassins are way too strong.
They're way too tanky to do any fancy fucking shit for Gwanyun.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
You thought you could- You thought you could fucking do that to me?
Get parried.
Get fucking parried.
Nice.
Bye, one guy.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking forever to die!
Come on, get you out of here.
And there's like three guys too.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm under-leveled or not.
I feel like I'm not because the main general story missions like the main story missions are not that hard.
They're just super tanky.
Yeah, I don't think so.
I'm just- They're just really tanky.
But they're like- Yeah, they're like bullet sponges, but like, not bullets.
Hahaha.
They're like- They're like spear sponges.
Okay, we prevented the assassination.
Perfect evade training.
Okay, we need to do this to defeat 100 enemies.
Okay, I'll talk to you later.
Oh wait, let me talk to you here.
I'm most grateful.
They sent assassins too, did they?
I'm pleased you were able to deal with them.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks to you, I was able to focus on fighting the enemy before me.
Very nice.
I am a sword.
My mission is to cut through the darkness and bring the dawn's light to the world.
Until I met you, I believe that I must fight through the darkness.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah, woah, woah!
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
Okay, Diao Chan, you gotta get in a line.
Oh, Diao Chan, I'm sorry.
There's a huge line.
Woah, woah, woah.
Oh my god.
What do you mean my wrist is too strong?
I'm doing nothing!
Like...
Like, I'm not doing anything!
They just...
They just come to me!
I'm nearly doing nothing.
They all just keep...
They all just arrive.
It's actually crazy.
It's actually crazy how I don't have to do anything.
Okay, let's get him out of the way.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Alright, I wanna... Okay, let me attack these guys so I can do this.
There you go.
That should be...
something, right?
That should have given me like ten.
The peasant is facing a desperate fight.
Is this not a peasant?
Right now?
Is this not a peasant right now?
Do not allow the peasants to be defeated?
I'm fighting one of them right now!
There's only one of me!
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading... Oh, I went the wrong way.
I'm going as fast as I went the wrong way.
I'm going as fast as I can.
Sorry.
Oh, I've... Oh, sorry.
Okay, maybe some peasants might die.
But that's okay.
Okay, okay.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Oh, this peasant is so fucking dead.
Oh my god.
I think the other... I think I might fail this one.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
Wait, they actually might die.
Okay, nice.
I broke it.
Okay, because they're so tanky, I...
I don't know.
It's not looking so good for him.
Because I'm still...
I'm still halfway across here.
It's like I parried this, but I'm not parrying it.
Oh my god, please.
Peasants, please live.
I really need you to live right now.
I'm still trying to kill this one guy.
Oh, damn.
So close.
Come on.
Just live.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Come on.
You can live.
I'm heading there.
I swear to god if you... Oh, I went the wrong way.
Please.
I'm heading there.
Oh my god.
You just... I got it.
I just made it.
Don't worry.
I did it.
I'm a hero.
There you go.
Get him.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh my god.
He just sat there while I was fucking fighting for my life for him.
I'm a hero.
It's okay.
Allows LBLY to evade.
Okay, nice.
The fact that he just stood there.
Just taking it.
I'm like, what the fuck are you doing?
Get up.
41.
Okay, 41.
Did I do anything with the YY?
8 people.
We're almost there.
We killed 8 people.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta get those like the...
Okay, we're gonna try and...
We're gonna try and do these.
I wanna at least get progress the Guan Yun route.
That's my only goal today.
That's my end goal for today's stream.
Shit, I keep accidentally jumping off.
My end goal stream is to progress the Guan Yun route.
Okay.
Come on, let me do this.
There we go.
That should be good.
Nice.
Alright, good.
Oh, I forgot to lock in.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Okay, we gotta kill the thief too.
Oh, what the fuck?
Get out of here!
I'm locking in.
This is important.
Oh, I get like...
I get like more stuff if I kill the thieves.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Oh shit.
And then we'll use that.
Okay.
Oh, I have to kill a hundred with this.
That's the worst part.
Come on.
That's fucking right, get out of here!
Alright.
Next one.
Not him yet.
I'll use this to start it off though.
The YYY.
Oh, you broke my combo!
No!
My combo!
You fuckers!
Stop breaking my combo!
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to progress my relationship with Guanyin!
This is fucked.
He's ruining this for all of us.
It has to be the left side.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, I found him.
Nevermind.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh my god!
I did one of them!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Where am I going?
Really, where am I going?
Okay, nice.
Parry.
Oh no, I can't even parry right!
Okay, YYYY.
Parry.
No!
Okay, let me eat the bread first.
Nice.
Okay, I got it.
Nice!
Use that spear!
Nice, I got another parry.
Good.
Okay, I'm locking in.
We're so close.
Come on.
No, I missed!
Fuck.
Come on.
You're so low!
No!
Nice.
The tables have been turned.
Okay, one more.
One more!
We have one more achievement left.
Nice.
24.
How much do I have left?
Jesus, this is taking so long.
Just for Guan Yu to notice me.
Guan Yu, please.
Just notice me.
Just please.
Just look at me.
That's all I want.
I don't like this one.
Jump backwards and launch able to... Okay, we gotta get that.
And then, I wanna get rid of the... Replay, perform a powerful performance swooping.
Sending surrounding enemies... Okay, maybe the severe... The savage thrust is better.
Yeah.
I feel like the savage thrust would be a lot better.
Okay.
Gotta grab this.
Apparently, it's taking a while to grab.
Alright, we gotta find...
Gotta find more of those mini areas.
Hurry it up!
Oh, nice.
There we go.
This should be it.
This should lead me to... Okay.
Defeat the bandit.
Oh, there's another one of these.
That's good.
That gives you more chance to...
Gives you more chance to fight.
It'd be funny if I find him right here.
Okay, no.
Thank god.
Okay.
It'd be like... It'd be funny, but like I really...
I really need to complete this.
Okay.
Gotta build it up.
Come on.
Come on!
I need more!
I need more XP for this!
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need like something for...
for my...
x-ray.
I need more.
Come on, I need more.
I need more!
Nice.
Oh, serious.
I should kill somebody.
Yes!
Good.
That's good.
I just need to charge it again.
Nice.
Get over here.
Okay, that should be a lot.
That seemed like a lot that I just got.
God damn it.
Okay, I'm not gonna kill you yet.
No!
That was the only... Okay.
That sucks.
My... Give me more RB.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Okay.
I should have killed some people, right?
I don't know.
Oh, please tell me that's it.
Okay.
Nice.
Parry.
Please.
It's for Guan Yun.
You'd understand, right?
Please.
It's for Guan Yun!
Please understand!
It's for him!
Okay.
Okay, no.
I fucked up the parry.
Come on.
No, I missed?!
Fuck.
I actually missed.
Nice.
Parry.
Okay.
Get out of here!
That's right!
Get out!
Alright, where are we at?
Holy shit.
This has to be the hardest challenge for Guan Yun.
For Guan Yun.
For Guan Yun!
How much more?
We're so close!
We need eight more!
Do it for him!
Alright.
Nice.
We're almost there.
Do it for him!
That should be it.
That wasn't it.
That wasn't it!
Oh my god, we did it!
Nice.
Okay.
We did it.
Alright.
Now that we did it, we might as well get the other guys too.
Okay, we completed him.
Let's see.
Yeah, we might as well.
To beat a hundred foes, we're using gauntlets?
Yeah, fuck it.
Might as well.
We might as well.
Fuck it.
Now it's fist time.
It's fisting time.
That's right.
It's time to fist.
Oh my god.
This feels so weak, guys.
Not gonna lie.
Holy shit.
It's fisting time.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
There's no way.
I'm pretty sure I can kill a hundred here.
The battle leader has rised.
You think I care about that?
I'm here to fist.
Come on.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
How am I still not at a hundred?
What?
Okay.
Oh, using battle arts.
Oh, whoops.
I forgot the most important part about this entire...
about the fisting mission.
I had to use battle arts.
Give me a sec.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
Alright.
Nice.
What's going on?
What?
I read.
Sorry, it took me a while to read, but I read it.
You're right.
Fisting is already an art.
Alright, plus nine.
How much did I...
Nice, plus 24.
How much do I need?
Okay, I need a lot.
Fire arrows that follow enemies holding the button increases the number of arrows.
I can fire arrows?
Oh my god, it's time.
I did it.
I can finally use my...
the weapon that actually matters.
Alright.
Where's Guan Yun?
Where is he located?
I did it.
I completed the mission, Guan Yun.
Where is he?
Wait.
Oh, Dao Chan?
Bro, I don't want to talk to...
Bro.
I already maxed out my bond with him.
Oh shit.
Bro, how did I already maxed out my bond with him?
Oh.
When do I get to talk to him?
But I did the thing.
I did the thing.
Oh my god, okay.
I guess I'll talk to Dao Chan.
I guess I'll talk to him.
But where's Guan Yun?
Where is he?
I wanted to talk to
him.
I did all that for him.
Guan Yun.
How do you still want me to do missions for you?
Elimination again?
Okay.
Calm.
Sad calm.
How do you have so many assassins?
Like, I just helped you.
That's crazy.
I literally just helped you.
And you still need help?
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what?
There's two of you guys now?
Oh my god.
I'm getting fucked up right now.
There's so many people here.
Oh, I missed the parry.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
Fuck, okay.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Come on.
Nice.
Cancel.
There's always an opening.
Jesus Christ, he's so fucking dead.
Still hitting him.
An opening.
How many more openings do you want?
Okay, nice.
An opening.
No.
Just all the openings, I guess.
Can I upgrade this?
No, not yet.
Alright, Diao Chan.
What do you want?
Alright.
Oh, no cutscene?
Cutscene?
Alright.
I'm gonna call it here.
I've accidentally raised my bonds with Diao Chan.
In one stream.
I literally met her today.
And I'm pretty sure we already maxed out our bonds.
I don't know how that was possible.
But like, okay.
I maxed out my bonds.
With the Dong and Diao Chan.
Out of all the people I was talking to.
I maxed out the bonds.
With people who I didn't think I would max out on.
And that was fun.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I'm so sad that like...
PC actually...
Oh wait, what are you still doing here?
Get out.
Sorry, not you guys.
This random stream here.
Thank you for the super chat.
The next mission has Lu Bu.
I recommend you keep going just one more.
I think it'd be cooler if I start off...
The next mission with Lu Bu.
Start off the next part with Lu Bu.
I think I'm gonna go with that.
Let me save my game.
I almost forgot to save my game.
Holy fuck.
After everything I've been through too.
Oh my god, I wish my game didn't...
My PC didn't literally fucking explode there.
I wish...
My PC didn't explode at last minute.
Like in the middle of the stream.
That was crazy.
A thousand kills and then my PC fucking exploded.
Like a thousand what?
You're like...
No, no, no, no, no.
We're not here.
We cannot.
We cannot handle a thousand kills.
But that was fun.
That was fun.
I had a great time playing...
Dynasty Warriors as always.
I think next week I might do two parts of Dynasty Warriors.
Because this game is incredibly long.
So I don't wanna like...
I don't know if I can...
I don't wanna be like it's three months and I'm still playing Dynasty Warriors.
So we're gonna have two streams for Dynasty Warriors next week.
We have two collabs.
One was actually from the Chariot Auction.
A collab where...
Where someone won...
One of the Chariot Auctions.
Where I was collabing with a person of their choice.
So...
And the other collab would be...
The Sloppy Sisters collab.
Where I proposed...
I was the one that suggested it because I wanted to play the Headliners.
So next week we're playing the Headliners.
With LimeWizSnuffy and Mintz.
I actually suggested the collab.
Because I was like...
I really wanted to play Headliners with some people.
And I figured that the game seems incredibly fun.
So yeah.
I brought the Sloppy Sisters back together.
For more four person collabs.
What's the game?
I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it.
It seemed really interesting when I was looking at the trailer.
It's basically we're journalists.
And we're trying to...
It's basically like...
Lethal... What was it?
Not Lethal Company.
What's the other one where you try to...
What's the other one that's sort of like Lethal Company.
But it's not like the one where we're taping...
Video streamers and stuff.
It's sort of like that, but we're journalists.
Yeah.
Content warning.
It's like content warning, but we're journalists instead.
But yeah.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.